hello everybody i regret to inform you guys that i have lost
another nap gotcha so will she ever learn you understand the
rights might be really bad but like when you hit it when you
hit it when you get it it feels so good you don't understand
i've been chasing that one that two hit wonder ever since
you don't understand it's it'll come back eventually i'll
eventually get it again it just feels so good when you hit
the gotcha guys you don't understand i i know it's i know i
keep trying and like the rights might be absolutely terrible
but like when you get it When you get that nap gotcha, when
you hit, when you hit it, it just, it feels so good.
It, it's, it's, it's, it's just, you don't understand it.
The low profit feeling just makes winning feel so much
better, guys.
It might be.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Skill issue, but I'm back, guys.
I'm, I'm back.
I'm finally, I'm finally back, guys.
The time, I'm out of the tunnel, baby.
No, no, okay, there's still, like, there's other work, but
the work that I've been working on is finally over.
music thank you the super chat thank you thank you that's
like no it did i did hit the gotcha like one or twice i
don't remember it's been a while it's it's been a while but
you don't understand when you win oh my god it's like that
high that you get 420 by the way
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It makes it all worth it.
It makes it all of this worth it.
Solid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're so right.
Woke up from a good 25 minute nap.
Pet the dog got snacks and soda.
Now I'm here.
Feels great.
Hell yeah.
NSD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should just gamble on it.
I'm doing it like.
I'm gambling everything, but actual, I'm doing, I'm, but
actual gambling.
I've never actual gambled before.
NSC, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Maxi, Samo, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you, finally, the sequel to Dad, oh boy, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you, but guys, I am back
tomorrow.
It's the big announcement.
A special announcement.
It's really funny to see you guys guessing what it could be.
It could be anything.
Because like now, now we have a surprise variable.
Because Chibi-Doki is going to be there with me for the
announcement.
So yeah, I can't really say.
I'm trying not to say too much of anything.
Because I don't want to leak anything.
So I'm trying to hold myself.
I'll be like, where were you on Friday and Sunday?
I'll never tell until tomorrow.
I'll I'll tell you guys everything tomorrow.
So, like, I can't say anything.
The only thing I can say about this trip, if you don't
follow, I didn't even realize, okay, I could, I didn't even
realize it could even, I don't know why it went viral, but
like, um, I, okay, this, the moment this happened, I
literally tweeted it out, because I was just like, what the
fuck happened to me?
like what is this actually happened but i was at a table
like this like restaurant in the airport waiting to fly back
uh waiting for like boarding to fly back home and then so
basically what happened was that while i was like you know i
finished eating but i'm just like lounging at the table
because i just you know it's a table i don't want to fucking
sit in the on the chairs at the at the boarding gate so i
was just lounging at a table after finished eating and then
this by the way even wrote down exactly what the mom said
right after because i was just so caught off guard but a
little kid like uh a little kid like came up to my table and
asked me a question and before i could even respond to it
the mom fucking rushed in and was like i'm not gonna dox
this kid's name but i'll call him tom that coder could not
be his name but it's not his name because i won't dox a
child for now um the mom rushed in and was like tom come she
doesn't seem friendly and then
Literally the moment she said that I let out a fucking Laugh
because it was so ridiculous like she was so it wasn't like
she's like Tom come she doesn't seem right She's like Tom
come she doesn't seem friendly and I was just like What
I was just like she did not just say that in front of me
I didn't even say anything to the kid.
Like, I wasn't, what am I going to do?
Being like, like, don't ask questions to the child.
Like, don't get, what do you mean?
I was literally on my phone.
Finished eating food.
And it's just, like, like, I was just like, She's like,
don't get near her.
She's gonna kidnap you.
I'm like, I'm in a public area.
I'm in a fucking public space, ma'am.
What am I gonna do to your child?
She says calmly.
I don't know what to say.
I can't be.
I have a resting bitch face, I will say.
A run kid.
Like, oh, am I a fucking dog?
Am I gonna fucking bite your kid?
Because, like, I felt like I was a dog.
like at that point um um i felt like i was a the dog is like
don't touch her she doesn't seem friendly and like i'm it
was just so fucking like i i just i just didn't like uh
putting believe the interaction that just happened anyway i
tweeted it and it uh it like went viral but i do have i
will, I've already talked about this before, uh, I do have a
resting bitch face, because, like, you know, I'm not gonna
fucking, I'm on my phone, like, I'm just on my phone, and my
default face is like, like, that's my default face, but I'm
sorry if it seems I was gonna fucking bite your child or
something like like I was I was just like it like got me so
off guard because like I don't know she I felt like I don't
know it felt like I was like a criminal or something like
the way she said that like it was so loud too she's not have
to like shout it out
restaurant uh papa smurf thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you shorts were literally toky bites thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you metty thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you the kid to do the world i
don't like to remember i don't even remember what this kid's
question is like i don't like like he was like sort of like
half mumbling so like i couldn't even like just like tell
what he was trying to ask me like i just i'll never know
i'll never know what the kid wanted to know like before his
mom like pulled him away i like the aura like she knows she
knows you hate children i would say okay look hate is a
strong word it would be like i don't care much for kids but
but but thank you msi for sponsoring today's stream pragmata
and i'll i'm here today to prove all of you guys wrong.
I'll show her.
I'm going to show everyone that I'm friendly and can be
trusted with children.
She yells out very calmly.
I'll show them all that I am a very friendly person.
Anyway, thank you to MSI for today's sponsor.
As you guys know, MSI has been a very consistent sponsor on
this channel.
Really shout out to them for always supporting me and for
supporting this channel.
They've sent me quite a few of the MSI monitors.
And so if you buy a selected monitor, MSI monitors.
monitor and post a review on a designated platform to claim
your pragmata pc game code so the link to the special
promotion is pinned in my chat and in the description uh
below um if you already purchased an msi product before and
purchased msi selected mpg qd OLED monitor you can get an
extra steam wallet up to 100 us dollars i think it is on the
na only but for the giveaway if you guys I don't remember
what we did last time, but I remember if you were not
residing in NA, uh, uh, I think you can still win the game
code as an emperor.
Yeah, because it's like a universal game code.
So it's a Steam game code, by the way.
By the way, at the end, at the end of the, uh, at the end of
the stream, I will be giving away, uh, 10, uh, Pragmata
Steam game codes, like as usual, like all MSI sponsors.
Uh, we're provided with 10 game codes, uh, you know, Last
time it was Monster Hunter, then Resident Evil, and now it's
Pragmata!
So, oh yeah, and also soccer too.
So at the end of the stream, I will be giving away 10
Pragmata Steam game codes.
So just stick by at the end for a chance to win the code.
Also, the rules for it is just that you just gotta make sure
you're following Doki merch so that you can DM them.
We're not gonna play the little mouse and cat game where you
tell us your Twitter and then we have to figure out how to
fuck to contact you and find you uh this like like last time
when we figured it out like we figured out how to do this
successfully when we figured out how to do this efficiently
this i took us a while it took us a long trial and error to
finally figure out to do this efficiently like you contact
them not us contact you uh so you guys have to contact Don't
worry, I'll link the Twitter account, the Doki merch
account.
After several attempts, we figured it out.
Like, the first time we did it, when we're like, what's your
Twitter account?
Make sure to tell your mom, like, tell us your Twitter
account.
So we know, and then we'll DM you.
We're like, no, you DM us.
Just make sure you prove that the YouTube, that is your
YouTube account.
If you win, be game code.
And you have to make sure.
DM them within 24 hours after you win the after you win the
giveaway.
So if you don't contact within 24 hours, you revoke the game
code because we're not because like we're not holding it for
like we were like, you claim it within 30 days type shit.
You claim it in 24 hours.
Not within 30.
It's a free game.
Guys, why are you claiming within 30 days?
You're like I don't want to get spoiled.
I don't i don't i don't want to get spoiled so uh but yes
claim it within they're like within 24 hours within 30
business days uh robert thank you super chat thank you thank
you what if i don't have twitter any longer it was time to
create twitter while we watch this pragmatist stream just
use it to claim giveaway codes just be like uh giveaway
dokey giveaway code claimer or something that's the account
info we'll all understand um like just for that like
if you win if you win obviously uh thank you for the super
chat robert thank you thank you uh damn thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you yay sponsor beyond estoki are
you responsible enough to take care of chok well this stream
will be here to prove you guys all wrong
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, I do use a MSI monitor, a QD OLED monitor.
And I, like I said before in the past, I really like using
the MSI monitor because mine is a 500Hz monitor.
And it's really good for FPS games, especially because if
you're especially if you're, I know I heard Pragmata is a,
is a shooter.
Sorry, I had to, I had to do a little pop.
right now um because I look I had a spicy poke bowl this
morning so you know I had to meet little and you get the
pops out but yes I do I do like I'll use a 500 Hertz monitor
because I am a very competitive person I like FPS games and
it really does make a difference when I swear to guy made me
like oh the human eye can't see more and it's a no do not
say do not rage me right now but the 500 frames does make a
difference it absolutely makes a difference do not rage bait
me right now like if you say if anyone that believes that
get a hundred get at least 200 frames and then try and then
try to go back like you can never go back the more you go
forward you can never go back it's like when the cars have
been invented you can't go back to the horse and carriage
like it's it's like it's like you can't come back from this
um so so the moment for those who are like oh i'm can't see
more than 60 frames get like at least 144 even 144 frames uh
even like 144 frames try that and then try to go back
because you can everything is like the moment you go
backwards.
But horse is so much...
Not good for your crutch, though.
If you're a guy, it's not good for you, I heard.
I don't know about women, but I think so, too, because,
like...
I'm pretty sure it's not good for guys for doing it too
long.
Alright.
Oh, what else?
What else?
I myself personally, personally, I'm using the MSI MPG 271,
271 QR, QD OLED X50.
So, you want to see the monitors that I'm currently using?
Like I said, feel free to click on the links pinned in my
chat or in the description below.
Thanks, MSI, for the sponsor today.
Anyway, back to my rant about children.
Which I have nothing against, by the way.
And I'm going to prove you guys right now.
When I take very good care of the child in this game.
I like I said.
I'm going to show everyone.
That I can be a good father.
I can be a good dad to kids.
I can be a good caretaker.
I actually heard a lot of good things.
I heard a lot of good reviews.
About this game.
because I was a little worried about it because it is
technically a new IP.
I mean, it is, and not technically.
It is a new IP.
So I was a little worried.
I was supposed to stream this game on launch, but like I
said, I was traveling.
When the game launched, I was traveling, so I couldn't
really stream it.
But it was very reassuring to hear that the reviews have
been really, really good.
Apparently, Rory sold a million copies, which is really good
for them.
It's really good.
Like, already, like, for a new IP, a million copies right
off the bat is very nice to see.
So, and it's a shooter.
It's a, I have no idea anything else about the game other
than there's a child following you around.
And it's also a shooter.
So that's all I know right now.
So I'm sort of going in blind.
At the moment, uh, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but,
but, but, want to talk about uh but there was something else
i want to talk about let me look at my notes uh oh yes the
girlfriend cover we got a lot of emails about this okay so
funny story uh the girlfriend cover is currently taken down
from uh from the streaming services distributor because a
lot of people were like what the fuck happened to the cover
after you said it's up on streaming services So this was
happening while I was traveling.
So the thing is, you know how there was a fake upload?
Like somebody re-uploaded our cover.
It's not because Avril Lavigne was like, what the fuck is?
No, no.
It's not anything to do with Avril Lavigne.
It's because of the re-upload or the fake upload by someone
who also used distro distro kit or whatever the fuck is
called the upload site uh distro kit yeah they apparently
also used distro kit to upload the song on streaming
platforms so basically we filed a takedown um uh we filed a
takedown on it before we uploaded our version and uh for
some reason started they they also thought my official
upload was also one of the fake uploads so we got an email
and was like um there was a claim on your song um and we had
to take it down anyway please contact the uploader's email
dokeycanread at gmail.com if this was a false claim which by
the way they also sent this email to doki can read at gmail
.com so they were like hey doki can read at gmail.com we
were notified we flagged that your upload was false please
contact the uploader doki can read at gmail.com if this was
a false claim but that's me though that's it that's
staff who said all this up was like she's like that's that's
us like what please dokey please contact dokey to resolve
your issue so um so yeah why would dokey do this to me why
would she foul a false how could she do this and foul a
claim on me how dare you dokey like
so we're just wait it's just it's just we're just waiting
right now because my staff has emailed the legal department
to be to figure out how to resolve our own claim on
ourselves uh we don't know how we because they took down the
false the the re-up the fake re-uploader they took it down
and then ours got approved and then somehow ours got flagged
as well because we only found it time and it was directly at
the fake re-upload so i don't know how i got i i myself like
shot got hit by friendly fire i fired the shot it went
through the other guy and then it like did a and then it i
don't know it hit a metal rod or some shit and then bounced
back and shot and it hit me too so it ricocheted back at me
somehow um
So, so I don't, I don't know.
Anyway, we were told, uh, because apparently, um, we were
told that it, uh, we went through the normal channels for it
to, uh, yeah, God, double kill and I was part of it.
Uh, so, um, we were told to just wait.
Like, we already contacted the, the, the proper channels.
We went through the proper channels.
get a resolve and it's just a waiting game um the legal like
we sent an email to legal department and they were just like
uh yes she used copyright claims she heard herself in the
confusion basically um so it's just waiting to see what the
fuck is going on i get like that's all i can say we're just
waiting to see like and but they said that like um one of my
staff contacted someone else that had a similar uh that had
something similar happen to them as well and then it's just
just after you contact them it's just a wait you just got
it's a waiting game so it'll eventually be back up it's just
we guys gotta wait and see uh i don't know how they said it
could take a couple of days they said it could take a week
or two so we'll see if you know if a real person reads our
email we'll see how long it takes for a real person to check
their emails uh within that But we hope that we hope that'll
get resolved we were told that it will get resolved from
other people that did had that happen to them as Well, so
it's just you just gotta wait So yeah, that's what happened.
We got a lot of emails about it because they're like what
the fuck happened to you know It was there and now it wasn't
now.
It's gone What was that movie called where the guy like
curved the bullet basically that's what happened to me?
I didn't mean to I was so excited that like the bullet hit
and actually curved it back to me yeah I curved the bullet
somehow but then I hit myself what else oh oh yeah Tomodachi
life came out but like I'm not sure if I'm gonna stream I
know everybody's streaming it same with Pragmata, everybody
stream Pragmata, everybody streaming the mouse, I don't
know, P.I.
Mouse Game, everybody streaming Tomodashi Life, everybody
streaming Pragmata.
I personally don't know if I'll be streaming Tomodashi Life
because there's my reason why.
Maybe I'll feel different later on, but like right now,
because like I cannot be as creative or funny as the people
on the internet, and it makes me so angry at myself.
Like, please, it'd be so, but it'll never be as
FASBARE.
And then they drew the kid and then fed Freddy to the kids.
Like, like, and they fed Freddy the kid.
And I was like, that's so funny.
I'll never be as funny as that guy.
I was just like, that's so funny.
I'll never be as funny as him.
it's just like they've done it whatever I do will never be
as good as this it's all downhill from here how can I
compete with that how can I how can I compete like yeah I
know it's so genius
and also like I don't also like I'm I don't have a little
I'm not doing it on the controller I need to buy a little
stylus to draw shit if I had to draw shit on it let me see
if I bookmarked this let me see I don't know if oh yeah and
then the little Among Us guy dude just so much funnier than
me here's one where the guy drew Among Us I was like oh
there you go I found it I found the Freddy one here's the
Freddy one.
I was like, I'll never be as good.
I've never been as funny as this guy in the Tomodachi life.
They've done it.
They figured it out.
I was just like, oh my God.
Why can't you be this?
I know.
I'm so mad at myself that I can't be as funny as this guy.
I
So, I don't know.
I don't know about play Tomodachi life.
So, so I'll think about it.
Because I know everybody is...
I know, but that one is so good.
It's so good.
I'll never be as funny as them.
that's why i was like i was thinking about it guys because
anything i'll do would never be as good as the guy that fed
kids that fed freddy fastbear the children that he drew
so anyway anyway i that's like what i feel that's how i feel
at the moment about tamadachi it's like Poképiea.
I actually stopped playing Poképiea after I saw people
building apartment complexes for their fucking Pokemon.
And I was like, what's the point?
My Pokemon will continue to live in the slums.
I, I was just like, my Pokemon will never be able to live
the good life.
They'll just live get slums so i i didn't continue i haven't
continued pokepia in a long ass time because i couldn't feel
i was like i was like i got so discouraged while looking at
twitter and seeing like someone building amusement parks and
shit and recreating palette down i was just like holy
fuck um but anyway anyway it's progmata time thank you thank
you msi again for the sponsor uh you see the best part is if
you think about this is the best part to show you guys that
I can be a really good parent because technically the child
can get abandoned if it's fully tied to you as a mechanic so
like I can't fuck this up in the way if you think about it
like there's no way I can fuck this up all right guys let's
play pragmata let's boot it up pragmata well I could
technically I can't lose the child the child might die but
like at least like like like we'll both die together you
know if she's tied to me
we're in this together in a way so i have to keep her alive
if i want to keep myself alive uh it's a good mechanic you
know i gotta keep yourself if you want to keep yourself
alive you gotta keep the child alive it's a good motivation
so i can't abandon her all right all right sound guy let me
know if all the sound stuff is okay uh let's see will you
I'm going to use mouse and keyboard.
All right, unless it's barely visible.
Why am I should...
I'll just do that.
Like, I don't even see...
Oh, there it is.
All right.
I mean, I still see her.
I'm just going to do a little bit.
All right.
Wait, can I go higher?
Oh, I was going to say, to commemorate today's special day
and month.
Nice.
Is the issue at yes.
I wanted to see how you get past 400 to commemorate today.
Today is the special day.
when it were like a hundred and that's fuck there are some
grandmys and grandpas that play video games uh do you guys
see that up here this that tweet about some oh wait no sorry
it was on tv that i saw this uh or was it no it was on
twitter i sorry i also uh i was in america uh on friday and
saturday that's where i realized how bad right now cartoons
are uh because i actually have to turn on okay so i finally
um when i have to travel um i finally decided to uh uh
what's the word i finally decided to uh i won't say unpack
oh to open to open my new iphone iphone 17 so my my other
iPhone is the iPhone 13 by the way it's this very old and I
finally decide by the way I've had this new iPhone 17 pro
max for around two weeks but it was just in the in its box I
just never opened it because I never had time to to open the
new iPhone I just figured like it's time for an upgrade you
know uh because uh my iPhone 13 um I didn't have any space
anymore so every time picture I had to delete I had to like
every time to do anything not even just pictures I literally
used up my entire space because it was a hundred and it was
like 120 gigabytes so and I had photos all the way from like
um for like I have like photos stored in my phone since like
for like maybe eight plus years basically so you know like
everything requires memory like even like get Discord
message, you get attachments or anything, you know, so then
I had to, every time, every couple, like a day, every day I
had to keep deleting stuff on my phone and then, so I was
like, I should really get a new phone with more space
because like I can't be, I can't still keep deleting stuff
on my phone.
I'm, I'm losing stuff to delete right now.
Like
I'm like I'm losing like space to delete.
I can't afford.
No, I'm paranoid about the iCloud There's too many instances
where iClouds get hacked and like I don't I don't want to
fuck with that.
So
I've seen too many instances, especially like as a as a
content creator.
I'm I worry about that I worry about it.
So I don't trust the cloud
So anyway so I finally you know since I was like you know
what you know there's some downtime when I'm over there over
there wherever it is everything will be revealed tomorrow
like whatever the forever the fuck I was and whatever I was
doing on Friday and Saturday I'll be revealed tomorrow by
the way I finally decided to open my new iPhone um why did I
tell the story I why am I telling Why am I telling this
story of okay, anyway I was just like why did I bring this
up?
I don't even remember why Where I've led what I've said led
to this You tell us
Okay, I okay anyway Anyway, oh, I was doing multiple segues
I was trying to talk about the cartoons, but let me just
talk about my new iPhone had the orange color and i fucking
hate it's like it's like the only color you can get for the
new iphone um but by the new iphone is like 200 plus
gigabytes thank god because i actually i really needed it i
don't have to delete stuff anymore off the phone um it's
it's very ugly i do not like i don't fuck with the orange
but it was also the only one left like it was and i i you're
like I'm sorry we don't have the other colors so okay miss
first world no you don't understand it's so ugly apparently
I just I because in my head I was like oh I'll just cover it
up with a phone case you can apparently like yeah it's
Garfield colored but it's like not even like good Garfield
color I mean I could get Garfield case it would work but
apparently for the new iPhone you can't even
ass like camera part at the top so like the top half has to
be uncovered just so and it's like it's like one third of
the phone like you can't you can't actually cover cover it
so so because it leaves it open any of the cases there
anyway i might as well get i'm gonna get a garfield i'm
gonna get of Garfield cases.
It's the only way I can make this work.
The camera is so fucking big that it's literally the entire
top half of the phone, by the way.
It's like, oh, not top half.
It's like one third of the phone.
So it's not like, oh, it's just a tiny bit peeking out.
It's just the top third of the phone.
Anyway, my other, the thing I wanted to actually talk about
was that uh um i checked out the tv like the channels and
everything and uh and i was like oh let's what's on cartoon
network it's all teen titans go i i thought it was a joke
you know how i you know i thought they stopped i thought
they stopped or that like you know like they They realized
the joke, the joke ended.
But it was literally like seven hours of Teen Titans Go on
Cartoon Network.
It's just like, there's no way because it tells you how long
each episode, like how long each show was on the guide
thing.
Like, you know, you can see like what's up next.
And it's like, it was like seven hours of Teen Titans Go on
Cartoon.
network.
I was like, there's no way that's the only show on
circulation right now.
I was just like, oh my god, seven, you know, like, you know,
two hours, that's fine, but seven, you have other shows.
Like, it's not the only show in circulation that you always,
IP-wise.
Yeah, it's that, or like, yeah, but it was Gumball, but,
like, not to the extent of Taking Titans Go.
Maxi, thank you for their super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Adult Swim, Tanami, I'm the only reason to watch Cartoon
Network anymore.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, but I finally, um, finally have a new phone, guys.
Uh, I can finally have a work phone where i just use it for
btubing and then my other act my other phone for also i was
so uh i was so not not used to the e-sim thing where like
you're you don't have to use phone cards anymore you can use
electronic cards for your phone i was like fancy that's so
fancy and i don't have to use the lighting port anymore
finally i can use a universal charger um yeah so i can
finally have i don't have to fucking be like they accept
lightning ports so uh finally thank god for that lawsuit
yeah usbc let's go uh but that's really all i wanted to talk
about about my new phone that i forgot like not forgot but i
was just i was just so busy um that uh that i just didn't
have the time to uh to open the package because I had to do
so much because like the thing is like it also I had like a
hundred plus gigabytes so I was really worried the transfer
will take fucking forever because uh the last time I did
transfer um the last time I did a transfer it took me hours
but apparently this time I think because I deleted a lot of
stuff I had to delete a lot I mean to be fair because I used
the maximum amount of space even then I was so surprised it
only took me 30 minutes to do I think because the phone is
newer.
So the technology was there to to like speed things up now
So it just took me 30 minutes this time I finally got a
moment to actually move my stuff over to the new phone.
Yay
I'm trying to see what else there's everything.
Oh, yeah now that the tunnel is I'm out of the tunnel I can
finally do long streams again uh you'll find out why i have
to keep cutting the stream short the last week or two uh
tomorrow like i said tomorrow everything will be revealed so
today i can stream as long as i want today thanks msi um all
right sorry i had a lot of stuff to say uh i had a lot of
stuff to catch up on there was uh but we're okay now now
we're now we can actually play the game Uh, I was also
struggling because I was like, how do I stream again?
It's been so long.
I forgot how to stream.
Alright, is there a motion blur?
Get that shit out of here.
The first thing I change.
Uh, we'll do 120 it.
Um, trust.
Oh.
Language.
Oh, Diana.
That Diana?
That's her name.
I need to make it...
Nah, we can all read the standard size.
Should be fine.
Alright.
Sound guy.
If you're here.
I hope you're here.
We're gonna play the game now.
I'll start in standard.
Start game modes where I can play people.
Like, action games.
Yeah, I'm fine with that.
It's a shooter.
It should be fine.
What's the worst that can happen?
I should be able to protect one child.
It's one kid.
Like, what could go wrong?
What could go wrong?
I'm pretty sure she can bend for herself, too, if she's here
in space.
She's a space child.
This is Research Vessel, Eurotus.
Edis, do you copy?
Over.
he should have kept the mask on oh wait who's which one's me
wait which one is me I heard the director for this game
worked on Melgear or it was the right Revenge or Melgear
Rising or Revenge and also near
yeah it ruined my immersion the nano revengeance yeah yeah
yeah Melgear revengeance yeah so the director this was his
first this is his first so like a project lead
this is his first time leading a pro like leading a project
so
he worked on Mir and uh in the nanobots game just print
something that big that's lunar filament for you it's
application I'm going to show that mom that I can be
friendly.
I'm going to be so fucking friendly.
Here to clean up their mess.
The best thing to do is meet us in person.
Well, then let's get in there and scope it out.
Corporate's waiting.
I'm going to show her.
She didn't have to say that part.
Part out loud.
In the public space.
Sound effects you set to seven, music to eight, and then
just bring up overall.
All right.
Can I do that here?
All right, no.
Just gotta listen to this for now.
She lives rent-free in my head.
It'll be like 20 years.
years later and I'll be like, I am friendly.
I'm good.
Yep, no problems.
Loud and clear.
Channel's online.
Okay, let's move out.
Hugh, everything alright?
What the heck?
I can't believe my name is Hugh.
This man got bullied as a kid.
I would have legally changed my name.
like the moment the moment i hit 18 i would have been like
it's time to change my name
what's wrong with you
oh no it's just like me for real for real of course they
gave him the kid Look, of course.
At least my name is a dokey bird.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for doxing your first name to me.
You, you ass.
A human.
That's good.
That's a human right there.
Come on, dude.
After you.
Oh, no, L.
Look what you've done.
You gave us too much power.
Now that we know your first name is you.
True.
Human.
Is that humongous over there?
Okay, sound effects, seven, music, eight.
All right, let me know.
I, we know your weakness now.
Let me know if the sound is better.
I turned up overall.
Okay, I need to fix this sense too.
What the fuck?
Why does, why does individuals?
individually that have to be adjusted.
I don't like that when I did adjusted individualize.
I like it when it's like all just linked together.
Oh, maybe that's a controller thing or some shit.
He'll get over it.
Yeah.
He gave us the power.
all right okay god damn it it's still so fast i swear to god
oh my god what this is control okay i was on the control
okay it's here mouse camera sensitive why like why okay all
right okay there we go why is it oh my god it was separate
control why is camera separate from the sensitivity.
Why not?
Kilbride 6 here.
Is it?
I don't even know if it actually is.
Sorry, I get really anal about it because, like, I cannot
deal with it.
I'm not a fast sense person.
I'm, like, I give me it's medium because I'm 800 DPI.
I'm just going to try if it does feel different.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
It does.
I could not even...
I just wanted to check if it does feel any different.
There we go.
Actually...
This is like the...
The cons of being an FPS gamer.
Sense really matters for me.
I mean, I wish I could do like 5.5!
I did...
It was 5.5!
it would be perfect because five is just a little too slow
and six is just a little too fast where is my 5.5 the cause
why am I born with this check out that big rig that muscle
memory too real sorry not my thing hey Nikki fill us in I
see someone didn't do their homework I'll leave the studying
to you I'm going on ahead.
Yeah, I need 5.5923241.45.
It's a limb replicator.
Okay, so let's say you can print almost anything.
A heart?
Stuff it makes breaks easy.
So, it seems crazy they're printing something that...
Oh, shit, that's all 3D printed?
That's crazy.
You won't print a heart, would you?
something than to improve its quality wait you saying this
place could just collapse at any second why was i born with
this curse you know better than that they wouldn't skimp on
safety standards you set it yourself it's cheaper to rebuild
i mean it's corporate thing the shareholders want to print a
satellite we shall print 3d print a satellite they they
don't know they don't care about safety it's all cost
efficiency here you wouldn't print on moon
all right here we go because you know they're they're the
ones that aren't on the moon all right we need to bring up
overall all right i brought up overall sound guy uh devil
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hi jokey
wanted to donate for the first time since it's my birthday
it was on the 14th I missed it.
Thank you for all for streaming.
Also, yeah, happy birthday.
Of course, Devil.
Happy birthday.
And then you give the super chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Devil.
Yeah!
Happy birthday.
Good birthday.
Project number.
Alright.
I guess I just explore.
Hello.
Everybody seems very friendly what could go wrong all
right oh nice parkour okay i can hover we're fine for
mineral unique to the moon known as lunum luna luna film and
can absorb and copy any information it comes in contact what
require for various upgrades in the shelter construction
still underway yeah what could go wrong yes sir all right
heels heels
I'm gonna move ahead.
You walked just though.
Wait, wait a minute.
I was ignoring all the signs where everything...
Oh, yeah, no.
Those obviously seem very friendly.
What is this rubble doing here?
Yeah, I wonder how this rubble got here.
Oh, crank overall.
Alright, let me crank up the overall.
those seem like very friendly robots you know it looks like
i robot they're very friend shaped
oh shit let's just make it easier and print out the murder
robots closer to us
it's more convenient you know we're gonna die to them anyway
we'll just we'll just
yeah let's just print the terminator real quick
that's a fast-ass free 3d printer now i understand why the
shareholders went with it oh and we oh we we give them
weapons i thought he was just gonna pick it up here back to
earth soon anyway just leave everything up to ai oh oh
that's too real and then they send us when the thing needs
fixing that's a bit too real oh laser swords too you can't
trust a bot no wonder they you they're revolts in front of
him hugh it's you're like you're just like the
Oh shit, there's an earthquake on the moon?
Yeah, it does not feel very safe.
I was gonna say, thank God that glass would be reinforced,
right?
Oh, oh, that's not...
Oh, he'll...
He's gonna be fine, right?
Oh.
If anything, he'll just float in space forever.
Surely.
Surely he mastered.
Oh.
It's okay.
It's on the other side.
It'll be fine.
It's okay.
It didn't land on him.
We didn't see blood.
No, it's okay.
He landed on the other side.
of the pillar that landed in between us.
The pillar landed between us.
Well, this turned out to be a hue mess.
Oh, shit.
There's the child.
Oh, we started off right off the bat with a child mechanic.
Okay.
All right.
Nothing to worry about, guys.
I can finally prove you all wrong.
Yeah, my daughter is already a doctor.
What is your kid doing?
Asian parent, kicking in right now.
Look at that.
I've already done it.
I've made it as a parent.
She's already a doctor.
Look at that.
She became a doctor at seven years old.
What did your daughter do?
watch seven huh like that turkey is gonna pack girl is gonna
be the new read boy i'm sure odin thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you that was my trigger phrase this
is ethos your autonomous base administrator unregistered
guest identified walker please remove him from the oh surely
that red glow means it's Oh, there's, oh, you're gonna help
us remove more rubble, right?
Oh no, who would have thought the non-friendly shaped robot
was not friendly.
Is there headshots?
Is there, is there a headshot?
18, okay, no headshots.
Oh, come on.
Oh my god, it's Y2K all over again.
Let the adults deal with this.
The adults are talking.
Oh my god, and she can hack?
What is your kid doing?
My daughter is a doctor and a programmer and a hacker.
She's an end.
Okay, let's see.
Hacking.
Reach the game to hack.
bro
moving the cursor across the hacking matrix and connected to
complete the hack placing enemies is an open state making
them vulnerable what the okay move cursor okay what the heck
was that there's no time to explain i i'm moving oh my god
how do you want me to oh i have to do that okay
I have to hack and shoot.
All right, I figured it out.
Tell me what's going on here.
Forget it.
Let's get away.
Tell me what.
Forget it.
Oh, no, I have to multitask.
Like, tell me.
Why are you talking?
Oh.
Is he screaming for joy?
See, I told your captain was fine.
To an extent.
Cut that, Earth.
How am I supposed to lock it?
I can open it.
Alright.
Uh, alt.
W.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Repair carriage.
Repair suit integrity.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's repair.
our suit our suit should be fine tonight hold oh i have to
hold it longer okay we're fine now
all right my shooter is fine now
it's dad's face oh my god and my daughter knows directions
so what's your daughter doing
oh all right passing through morrow enhances hacking
increasing damage and keeping the hacking again that's right
you're not gonna get us in trouble all right all right oh my
gosh better Ashley and Grace oh my god I didn't think it'd
be possible I didn't think it'd be possible to actually have
children that do their job all right dodge my dodge too okay
dodge jump all right okay I mean I don't really have to oh
shit never mind oh my god finally the children are carrying
me hum please request more all right okay we gotta boost up
the overall real quick guys finally i get to feel what it's
like to be carried by the ai oh my god i've been waiting for
this moment for so long it's finally happening guys oh my
god children actually be see i told you look at that i'm
such a great parrot my daughter it only took me like one
minute of raising her and she's already a doctor an engineer
a programmer i i totally Look at that.
I'm such a good mom.
Hacker to every god and every that the game doesn't have a
river gun in it.
Look at that, guys.
Okay, I can sprint.
I almost forgot about that.
I made it.
What's your daughter doing?
She's gotten to harbour.
What school did your daughter get into?
I heard you're doing this sort of like hands-free type
parenting.
And how is that doing for you?
I'm going to keep leaving.
Your daughter is an AI.
Wait, what the fuck is going on?
Yeah.
Your daughter's taking a gap year to figure out what to do
with her life.
That's always around here.
The cool odd your mom leaves you with her cheap babysitting.
That's your ass sitting with a super chat.
Thank you.
Tocky.
I am D-I-033.
No, the truth.
Alright.
I possess basic life-safing protocol.
Pragmata?
It's not pragmata?
I need the user's manual.
I do, though.
Alright.
Next question.
What the hell is going on here?
And why are these things trying to kill us?
I don't know.
But I thought... What do you mean?
No, no.
You're literally connected to the... Your AI.
Yes, they don't need...
He is me, for real, for real.
He is me.
I wonder if the other robots hate her.
The other ones don't even get to be like have like cosmetics
or anything.
I'm a hue mess right now
All right, it's time out time Oh my god, I'm actually
playing as myself right now Same hue, same
Me too
One pragmatist and one adult He's just like in a dokey
simulator at the moment.
Someone get me an iPad right now.
All right, Diana, let's go in.
License level zero.
Reactivating primary functions.
Don't worry, I am a very good father.
I'm a good dad.
I won't mess up this kid She's so much nicer to another
blonde we know that chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like my second chance
Holy fuck what?
So relay channels are locked down about the comms tower Oh,
we can go even higher Alright, let's go even higher with the
volume all right let me know sound guys this is high enough
okay can you repeat that diana look at this the tram lane
leading to the solar power she's possessed which we can ride
the rail all the way to the tower okay what do you think
it's not even that far diana yeah
what see this spot You think we can get here in one piece?
What does your program say, Diana?
What?
Use your degrees.
That works so hard.
That works so hard sending you to college for.
You know what?
Oh, the Yolo strat.
I like that.
Ah, the plan of no plan.
See, she is my daughter.
You can...
Oh, no.
I was trying to...
What did the instructions say?
I was trying to boost my volume.
You know she's my daughter.
The plan is we're going in with no plan.
Guys, what was the instructions?
Because I had to tap out to increase the volume.
Did anyone see the tutorial?
Why can't we even fall?
Did anyone see the tutorial, guys?
guess we'll never know all right yeah I'm gonna need your
support till I'm back home it's pretty fun talking like this
let's talk a bunch while we have the chance all right oh
we're bonding around you the more you seem like a real kid I
wonder how many bots like you are hanging around she's
better than she's It's better than a real kid, to be honest.
Here you go again.
Diana, I heard you.
All right.
Let me ask you something.
Just how smart are you?
Smart?
What's that supposed to mean?
I don't have any special add-ons installed.
So you don't know anything about what's going on here?
Oh, it's the base price.
I got paid $59.99.
for the DLC.
Oh my gosh, she actually is ChatGPT.
No, it's okay.
I got a solid DLC.
Oh my gosh, she actually is just a chat bot.
Journal for acquiring upgrading various items.
Exchange to upgrade weapons and hacking nodes or unlock new
ability.
Okay, well, clearly wait.
Oh, I don't have anything.
I also do not have enough money for this.
I don't think I need repair stuff.
I feel like I would need, like, hacking or damage.
What is this?
Oh, Ron needs more upies.
All right.
Oh, my God.
What did the tutorial?
I did it again.
What did the tutorial say?
I tapped out.
I'll never know.
What was the tutorial?
I tapped it.
I had to raise the volume.
This is for upgrades.
Okay, at least we know it's for upgrades.
What is this?
Oh, I guess this is... Oh, there you go.
Yeah, what is this?
Oh, is this my 3D printer?
Whoa.
Is everything in here talk?
I mean, that's good.
I don't...
We have instructions.
All right, today's my 31st birthday.
Feels old man.
Can you sing a happy birthday for me, please?
If not, that's why.
Hope you and Dragoons have a good day.
Love you, Doki.
Of course I can, Aiden.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Aiden.
Yay, happy birthday.
We have a great birthday.
All right, let's go.
No matter what There's always one thing that's missing It's
a map Can I get is my little chat At Diana At Diana PT Where
do I go Locker controls Don't keep proving she can't read
Music thank you with a super chat Thank you thank you That's
what we should make for the power plant Alright you board
the tram The shuttle travel to tram station and other
sectors.
Oh my god, this is just dead space, but like, what if I was
a dad?
Before departure, review your loadout, make any adjustments
needed.
Well, I don't have anything, so this is my loadout.
It's default time.
It's like an extraction shooter.
I go in with a default gear.
Alright.
Yes.
Dad space time.
I hope he'll be okay.
all right see i told you i can't abandon the kid if he's if
she's like attached to me
okay uh the powerpoint is entering emergency mode create
powerpoint is currently limited to 35 for standard capacity
trams and supplemented facilities are now non-operations
destroy restart the main okay that's what i have to do
All right.
There's no way I can lose this kid.
Looks like we have a power switch nearby.
All right, that has to be where the robots come up.
This has to be where that's road.
That is literally like, what is that supposed to do?
What is that container supposed to contain?
That's human, like, that's as tall as a person.
Like,
What would that contain?
Please, pray, tell me.
That looks like a 3D printer for humans.
It's a word in the kit.
All right.
Diana's scan.
Oh, nice.
Okay, she can scan.
Oh, my God.
What can't she do?
So my daughter can scan things?
Um...
I heard your kid is in a Pokemon.
My kid can scan enemies from five miles away.
Be a true human.
Hologram's surveillance.
It has come to my attention that simple mistake I made got
caught on hologram.
Now the recording is being spread around the crater.
I enjoy my work, but it doesn't.
foster a positive work environment knowing that everything i
do could be a subject of criticism or a joke is it really
necessary for all operations to be recorded with such strict
surveillance i regret to inform you upon joining cradle your
grief to a contract acknowledging that all are
areas except where uh designate private zones are subject to
continuous 24 out wow that seems like a very nice work
environment honestly i sometimes 24-hour surveillance, even
the bathrooms?
I always say sometimes wonder if the company is pushing the
boundaries with this policy.
But I suppose Delphi wants to leverage access to
state-of-the-art tech to strengthen security measures,
cradle-wise.
I'm sorry I could not provide a more concrete answer, but
rest assured, your concerns have been noted.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Dr. Hacker, Scanner, all that.
She'll become a YouTuber when she grows up.
Shake my head.
Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Let's see, thank you for the Super Chat, thank you, thank
you.
How's your daughter in mental health doing, Miss Dad of the
Year?
See, I didn't buy the DLC for mental health.
I made sure to not include that in the DLC.
When the DLC
can't have it.
Don't have the words.
about that if I just don't buy the DLC for it.
Mental health option.
All right.
Oh, wow.
Well, who would have thought?
All right.
This game is so easy.
Me and my kid look at that teamwork what where else am i
supposed to go what the that's why is that a dead end oh my
head oh because there's a door right here sorry i don't look
left and right on the sidewalk Apparently.
Every rookie on a team gets thrown out by the first lockdown
drill.
You're not alone.
Just operate terminals located in an active sector.
It's a signature locks.
Most problems sort themselves out once you're at the
controls.
Oh, that's nice.
Do you know?
Alright.
Control.
Jump to dodge.
I don't know.
Wait.
Where's the controller?
Oh, that's a...
Okay, there we go.
We know now.
Okay, we know it's a dash.
All right, now we know.
Now we know.
All right.
Is that not?
Oh, shit.
Too long.
Okay, I didn't realize she can't hack for too long.
Okay, we can't hack that yet.
Nice.
I assume when there's multiple, it gets a little harder.
All right.
There's no multiple.
What is that?
okay all right there wait which objective there's two oh
that's another tram system there we go there is the two two
bots all right there must be an upgrade where i can hack
multiple bots at once right it's over all right nice easy
server terminal now the power plants entered oh wait i was
here oh i looped okay i looped now the door is accessible
now i'm sorry this is okay i won't say i'm directionally
challenged but like i do have a pro like i don't know if
it's just me but when i'm in a sci-fi environment everything
just looks the same like I don't know like do you ever feel
like the aesthetic is very similar that is all right all
right I will figure out what that oh oh shit
I'm jiggle peeking right now.
Alright, nice.
Okay, she can hack this.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Wait, it had the instructions.
Can you not hack this?
Oh.
There we go.
I need to press alt.
Peekaboo.
What is that?
When in Apex, when you just...
Oh,
I have the whole...
Yeah, I'm blowing you stuff great.
In Apex, when you, like, jiggle peek the corn.
It wasn't...
It's not jiggle peeking.
There's another word for it.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I got too fast.
Oh, I can hack the other door.
You're right.
Another door.
It was, like, right here.
This door.
cradle staff at easy access maybe i'm not sure
no okay there you go all right oh yeah toes lore you heard
her she doesn't even have hp guys there are no kids
still plenty of work that only a human can do like thinking
up new innovations AI.
They can only get info from what they learn.
They can't really like like they're just like regurgitating
information.
From what they were able to process.
Merchicissa repairs minor damage.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
He is.
Yeah.
Can't create something new.
It's like that guy.
That... Oh my god.
Did you guys read that?
that article where they have an AI to basically proofread
all like business statements or whatever.
And then because the AI didn't want to like fail, they just
approve everything and made up numbers to be like, yeah,
it's working.
And then a guy double checked and was like, wait a minute,
none of these numbers actually add up.
They're like, wait, wait a minute.
How is this?
How is this approved?
All right.
Ooh.
Lockdown.
How is this my fault?
Oh, sent here to repair shit.
Nope.
How you like this?
Hey.
All right.
Nice.
Easy.
Oh my god.
Positive reinforcement.
I'm already better than it.
other parent
emerging exit allowing travel to and from the shelter leads
to lower tram stop holds eat on target to unlock enable use
back at the shelter you can upgrade print uh yeah see parent
of the year i gave one positive reinforcement to my child
now she's gonna carry that for like now she's always going
to chase that high of me is complimenting her like see if
you give one a year she'll make sure you don't give too much
because then it won't be as special so you so she'll always
chase that high toky that seems pretty that's it yeah but
your child a doctor
That seems a little Back at the shelter You can upgrade
print or enhance Gear Cover and refill Repair cartridges
Music Thank you for the super chat Thank you Thank you
That's like the AI they made To play Tetris as long as
possible It paused the game You don't even need AI for that
I do it That's called loopholes there wasn't a loophole that
said you can't pause the game uh line travel to leads to
lower tram stop hold e to unlock enable use back of the
shelter be aware that emin's will respond oh oh that's souls
like that's basically like a souls like mechanic it
literally is a 3d printed thank you for the super chat thank
you she's real to me i can just go home I mean, I did power
it up
Alright, we're back home Yay Good to know If things get
crazy, we can head back for a breather Okay, I thought we're
heading Okay I thought we had We're heading back, I didn't
realize I had to James Bond this shit
Alright Wait, what?
Oh.
There we go.
Hack the power terminals for the...
First one down.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Feels like there might be enemies down here.
We'll see.
Oh, yeah.
I wonder why they give me a new gun.
Pretty suspicious.
Alright.
Unhack a special and frontal.
Oh, it's a shotgun.
And make enemies easier.
stagger becomes less effective as oh it's literally a
shotgun yeah what if it ain't really do i have to body shot
or does it does headshots i mean you cannot be printed at
the shelter or not i get to keep this use that one up close
nice oh shit not nice oh my god this takes fucking forever
to reload, though.
Oh my god, he can dodge.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm happy to see Capcom be enrolled this year.
So many amazing Capcom games count and all of them.
Yeah, they've been doing really well.
Capcom was out with the releases.
I remember when I was talking to the during Capcom Cup, he
was telling me how he really really enjoyed Pragmata and
like that like to look forward to it.
So I'm glad I'm glad that the game is very well received.
Because he like vouched hard for the game too.
Wait, what happened to my other gun?
Oh, it just disappears?
Wait.
It expired?
Oh my, you could tell this gun was 3D printed.
Sorry, I didn't use the right filament for this gun.
I didn't subscribe to it.
I always forget about the scat.
I don't know if this...
Okay, there it is.
That's where I have to go.
Oh, I hacked him!
Okay.
I didn't realize I hacked this guy.
I'm reloading?
To be fair, they don't really target very well.
Yeah, don't you hate it when your 3D printed gun
disintegrates?
Yeah.
I'm sorry, I used paper filament for my 3d printed gun i
didn't subscribe i didn't subscribe uh to the one year trial
i just need another email so i can get another 30-day trial
on that gun all right let's see i definitely need more
stamina i think i'm gonna i'm gonna upgrade hacking first
right the hacking should be the better upgrade first all
right what's this is that
Tactical unit that fires a spiritual Electromagnet expands
on impact and blah blah Oh, it's a Zariot gun Aim fire Oh,
yeah, it is
Why do I need to shoot it more than once?
I don't know what Am I shooting that?
Shooting the same gun?
I get the hack out And then Oh, it's just me hacking again
okay this gives me more time to hack i see it gives me more
time to hack yeah
look at that she also counts for me yeah there you
go Oh my god, I wish I had another subscription for this.
Oh shit, where's my ceases?
Oh shit!
That's what I've been trying to do!
Alright, nice.
I'm reloading, I'm reloading.
Oh, this is bad.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Okay.
All right.
All right, there we go.
That's all right.
Oh, we got to subscribe.
Guys, what's the last three digits of a credit card?
I got to subscribe to this gun real quick.
All right, nice.
Oh, I could still hack this, I guess.
Like this.
Pragma being the new IP for I've Capcom is also amazing.
God, it's doing very well.
Considering the...
Yeah.
Also, the fact that it is a new IP, which is really nice,
too.
Because we don't get a lot of that late.
You know?
Everybody's always, like, doing sequels and stuff.
So I'm glad that we're actually able to get a new IP.
Quick, we need to verify your age, too.
There was another thing down there.
I knew that wasn't the last of them.
I saw this.
No!
Oh no!
I didn't get here!
Oh shit, okay.
Okay.
Oh My god, no I fell down
I fucking fell down Oh, no, where am I?
Where is I forgot one Oh my god, I'm back here I was so
close
I just didn't know where I fell down Okay, those attack
units are your class specialized for your skill.
I have to do it all.
Oh my god.
I got so greedy.
I don't know.
Going to upgrade levels.
Tackling your class weapons.
Switch to K-Shift.
The battlefield creating weapons assist in hacking.
Okay.
I feel like I have to upgrade the hacking stuff.
It was just all a dream.
Hacking, right?
All right, Diana.
It's like an actual raising kid.
We're going to go all in on your college tuition.
We're going to go all in.
All right.
Hacking open duration.
Which is, which is, but is it hacking that's, uh, we're all
going all in on the college fund, guys.
All in.
Some student upgrade might be good, it's too late.
She, she is my retirement plan.
I don't know, have a little fun mini spot somewhere, give us
a job, and we'll beam right over to your living quarters.
this is my retirement plan right here wild i'm gonna grab
the shotgun there we go i don't know you've been with that
child for less than an hour you're already caused it's that
she didn't die i did she still lived she's my plan b guys
Oh, we got him.
Yay!
I printed the gun.
Look at that.
Guys, I finally subscribed to their gun.
Tram terminal.
How do I repair myself?
Anyway.
That big ram bought from before was pretty tough.
Ugh.
Get caught under that thing with no suit on and it's game
over.
Hell no.
Not working anywhere with those guys stomping around.
Yeah, because they fell into them i saw like a little shiny
thing i saw a little shiny thing and i was like i have to
get it and i missed i still managed to miss that oh i can
upgrade it more i guess okay damage uh i'll just upgrade
damage for it i'm gonna do it for yeah damage for other over
up a little bit all right up it a little bit more let me
know if it's better sound guy i've upped it a little more
it's very so's like i realized uh i have clip it here we're
gonna get me clip at the tram and take him from the shelter
in anise okay grab that here
i got everything in me ride the tram where was i was it here
yeah here it is
All right.
It's not permanent.
Sorry, I went for the cheapest option on my subscription.
You remember that floaty watcher bot thing that was shooting
at us?
Yeah, I remember.
Wait, I have to go back.
Where was it?
I'm going to grab that gun, though.
Oh, no.
Notting.
Again!
There we go.
It's okay, I'm just... Oh shit!
Oh shit.
There we go.
I'm trying!
Adam, please!
I have to reload!
Alright, reload.
All right, backward.
Okay, I have to get that thing.
That shiny thing is calling for me.
Okay, it was like right over here.
Do you see it?
It's like right over here.
You see it, right?
It's right there.
Okay, how do I...
Okay, all right.
I can make it.
I swear.
All right.
Also, how do I...
What is down there?
Okay.
It's right there.
You see that?
It's shining.
It's calling for me.
Oh, but these are calling for me too.
Oh my god, they're all calling for me.
I made it!
Okay, okay.
There we go.
I told you.
I told you it's calling for me.
Don't worry.
I can slowly...
Okay, this might take a while.
Oh my god, this other one is also calling for me though.
Do you see that?
Do you see it, guys?
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm trying not to get CC'd right now.
No, there's no way it can hit me from here.
I'm really on high ground.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
It can't do anything.
What you gonna do?
That's right.
I have the high ground.
I can hack forever.
There we go.
That's right.
Get cheese.
Okay, I'm just gonna wait here.
That's right.
How you like that?
All right.
That's right.
How are you going to target this?
Easiest kill of my life.
Look at that, guys.
I told you.
I told you I could get the shiny thing.
Okay, well, we reset the hack.
Whoops.
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know that?
How was I supposed to know that would go there?
Okay, that's not intuitive, guys.
Hey, there's something over there though.
What's over there?
How did I know there was a platform there?
I thought it was something else that was shiny.
Oh my god, that jump scared me a bit.
I swear to you guys, are there any funky platforms that I
should be aware of?
Nice loot.
Is that open?
Oh, does that close?
Oh, it just closes that.
I always feel like I have to reload, but it's just
recharging.
No.
You're like, yeah, I'm just gonna do that.
And I don't waste my shotgun though.
I feel like I'm gonna have to get more ammo.
I wish I could melee them.
It would be so easy, so I don't have to worry about, uh,
about like ammo situation if I could just melee.
in this mess if we even come here then nick and the others
will still be all right i need to close this apparently no
that was james the captain those two plus yeah and he's very
much alive
friends yes don't worry you have friends too right look at
that got the shiny another shiny get Told you.
I can smell all the shinies.
There's no shiny there.
Wait, how do I get that?
I don't think I can make that one.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
I don't know.
There's so many.
How do I get out of here?
Um...
Do I'm like here?
And I jump here?
Wait, how do I get over there?
Oh, oh, no, oh, I made it.
I made it.
Wait, where was the shiny?
It was, like, on this platform, right?
That platform?
Okay, okay.
No!
It's fine, it's fine.
Uh...
I think it's, like, here.
I'm greedy.
That's free upgrades.
Eh, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
We had a great time.
stream okay there you go see guys i told you i told you i
can get the shiny
um okay i what is that oh there yeah oh it's like metal gear
oh yeah shoot the easter eggs looks like the printing messed
up here definitely can't go that way that's like one dollar
we don't need that we're fine oh Oh, it's when I have to
open the gates here.
Okay.
Alright, now we can leave.
We're good now.
Unlock, please.
Go down or up?
Oh.
I mean.
We get upgraded and then we go down.
What's this?
Is that the elevator?
Thank god there's no fall damage.
Okay, that's the elevator.
elevator oh
do i need to bring up the overall volume a little bit more
sound guy
that's the earth the blue part there is all ocean look
outside and you can see it from here i'm feeding ai
information right now i've got half of it here yeah where's
the other half oh okay the printer's busted all right i'll
boost up the volume a bit more
all right let me boost up the volume a bit more all right
let me know if it's better i should boost up a little bit
more too
water everywhere kind of hard to training my ai listen we
get back to the shelter i'll look you up make her a doctor
lawyer I want to see Oh yeah, she's never been to the earth
before She's a moon child Some days the world can feel so
big Other days it can feel so very small Aww, I give her the
Equipment accessories Oh, that's cute
Okay Thank you for purchasing Read Earth Memory Simply
insert this rem chip into a supportive Replicator to
successfully generate friendship displays and more when
you're looking to refresh your interior recreate a memorable
scene or set up a temporary office let your creative
creativity guide you oh nice see you guys who needs that's
crazy i feel like the 3d printer is actually such a good
investment only because like uh hello why can't i oh what
okay i was gonna say my crosshair was on him I feel like you
can just 3D print a lot of like stuff these days instead of
actually buying.
I feel, but filament is expensive though, right?
I feel like a 3D printer is a good investment long-term
wise.
Just to, like, 3D print, like, stuff you might need.
I don't want to hear either.
Damn.
I gotta hurry and contact Earth.
Oh, is filament not expensive?
quality film yeah well you need quality shit like or else
it's just gonna keep breaking the key to living on the moon
and advancing uh research and development was ensuring
access to a stable power supply because like i saw like
there's this like video series where they were like um um
where they were like trying to convince my girlfriend that
uh my 3d printer was worth it investment and he was just
like printing like like her cooking equipment was breaking
and he was like printing like like handles and stuff for
like for cooking and stuff because the handle broke off of
her pot or something so she didn't have to buy a new pot she
just printed out a hat new handle for her I thought wait oh
my gosh wait that's actually pretty convenient like like
it's like good DIY like you know if something breaks you can
just print a new thing yeah I was like wait a minute I think
I think he's on to something I don't have to go to IKEA
anymore I could just print a shelf like I could print it
what if I just print myself a table like it's better my
table my IKEA tables are already made of cardboard anyway I
feel like plastic is the next upgrade like I
he's quite he's cooking right now it's fair to say that the
advanced system in place at our solar power plant have been
a backbone for supporting delphi's development and expansion
at the cradle key to living i mean i literally printed a
child like i mean you could 3d print an ear now you guys
hear that did you guys read about that you can 3d print like
Uh, you can have 3D print, like, like, uh, organs and skin.
Yeah, people, like, they figure out how to 3D print skin.
I didn't, oh my god, there's this nice nude mod pack.
Hardened soon.
Equipping mods.
Yeah, you just get stem.
You just, like, instead of using film, like, the stem cells
are the filaments.
Equipping mods.
specific abilities.
Oh my god, I got the mod packs, guys.
It creates special effects.
Change.
Oh yeah, I heard about 3D printing me.
I don't really trust that part one, though.
I think, like, there's a line at the moment and, like, I
think, like, oh, you draw the line on me.
It's pretty gross.
I will have to say, 3D printing me.
Like, it's just Just fucking cut a cow.
Like...
Yeah, that's where I draw the line.
But if it's 3D printed, all right, sign me up.
Change locations at the tram equipment mods, change loadouts
at the tram terminal menu in the equipment mods.
All right.
Yeah, I draw the line on 3D printing a cow.
I heard it doesn't taste as good too Like if I'm gonna eat
I'm gonna eat something nice Oh yeah cows are You guys hear
I heard about that Like we have too many cows because cow
Farts are right It's actually Like hurting the environment
because Cows fart too much that it's Giving us too much
carbon dioxide I think that's Like wild
Things at Solar Plant or in a world quiet grunt grunts like
us or sorry methane fart yeah methane farts uh sorry not co2
it's methane it was one or the other I couldn't remember
what it was but yeah it was just too much methane gas
because they like to fart a lot it shows in the morning and
check they're very gassy bots have planned for a day and
then we spend the rest of the ship trying to look busy gets
you thinking we're both in but you ended up on the front
lines of learning development and me wish i could be out
there too bots did all the work
damn oh man my steak is too juicy and my steak is too juicy
man
i was here
oh oh no not my tv I always forget the scan mechanic.
Oh, I can't crouch.
I can only dash.
My lobster's too butter and my steak is too juicy.
All right, that's where I can...
I'll grab that.
Hacking nodes have special effects that trigger when patched
through.
When completing a hack, a hacking node that disrupts enemy
Ontario's system.
Temporal increasing would be the use on the same enemy
reduces its effectiveness.
Passing through multiple nodes of the same type.
boost damage third order okay hacking mode that disrupts
temper increasing damage should repel you use other than
reduces passing through mode on the same type boost damage
further okay we can use this to hit harder actually since
there's no enemy i should i'm just gonna go back to terminal
and use my upgrades like there's no point like it's enemies
reset but i have no enemies right now so go home right now
yeah i'm just gonna go home and spend it yeah the only
there's no enemies to respond i can just come back here look
at that see i'm using my brain doesn't happen very often but
but look at that
we're your fun little buddies mini i thought i already
looked at this i know they're my fun little buddies The
dokey brain has been expanded.
And I have the hacking now?
And there's an internal system.
Quit use, I'm saying reduces effectiveness.
Alright, let's just buy that since I do have some money for
it.
Alright, subscribe to another plan.
I only have one month.
I only have a 30-day trial, guys.
I need you guys to give me your email so I can just keep
on...
So I can increase the trial period longer.
We need more emails.
Best sound, guys.
Is everything okay now?
Alright.
Keep doing, keep hacking!
All in!
Toki, what about... All in!
I don't need to do damage if she just invests it all on her.
What about your base gun?
Why not?
Don't keep all in on the college, but she's my retirement
plan.
Let's get lots of REMs and decorate the shelter.
Hey, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You remember your other daughter?
It seems you forgot less than the new favorite kid.
Look, I have custody of her tomorrow, guys.
Today is Diana's day.
This is a kid I won't fuck up.
I got a second chance, guys.
Glove.
Here's the globe.
Look at that.
I got her a little present.
It's not because of a special occasion.
I just got it for her because I care.
I'm such a good dad.
all right here you go featuring a smiling robot and a hat
better hold on to it just in case cabin coin coin give the
read earth memory to diana and shelter and print it using
the rem replicator they might keep her entertained for a
while oh is she entertained oh look at Look at that.
Poor REMs, Hugh.
The globe makes the earth seem small.
Like it's easy to just go anywhere.
But I know it's Diana's day.
Tomorrow's Cheevy's day, guys.
I thought the exact same thing when I was your age.
That if I worked hard enough, I could go anywhere.
Truth is, if you're up for it, nothing's stopping you.
Aww.
Alright, go play.
Oh no!
I distracted Go, go, come on, come on, play with the globe.
I didn't get to see your interaction.
No, now you're bored.
I just printed this for you.
I used up so much filament for this.
There's no way you're bored already.
There's no fuck.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Now, there you go.
I thought if I talked to her, it was me talking to her while
she plays on the globe.
She's like, I'm bored now.
Oh, that's cute.
What am I going to do with the coin?
I mean, I guess it'll tell me later.
Oh, that's cute.
Let's see.
All right, let's go to the next area now.
I'm having fun so far.
I really am.
Open.
Okay, you quit mods.
Yeah, I quit mods.
Nice.
Increase my HP.
Don't really have anything else.
Yeah, only have defense.
Weapon load up.
I'm ready to ride the tram.
They definitely, for this new IP, I really like the
mechanics, the hacking and the shooting mechanic.
I mean, like, like it's a...
It's definitely very unique in a way.
You have to be able to multitask for it.
I should like the swapping the guns around to make sure like
crowd control everything as well
All right now we go in I feel like I have to put this one up
Oh There you go I'm glad I'm playing our mouse and keyboard
for real All right, I can pick this up again too
Yeah, okay.
Okay, that's a window.
I'm sorry.
I mean, it's transparent.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
I thought it was just a smaller door.
Okay.
But what's over here?
I hear him.
I hear it a little.
Yeah.
Okay, I have to go here.
I'm gonna go up.
I'm going up.
There might be other stuff up here.
There might be a little shot.
Yeah, I knew it.
I hear him.
He's calling for me.
That's great, get.
Where is it?
I hear him gnawing.
Nah.
Where is he gnawing?
Oh, I see you.
Bingo.
all right i'm gonna put the stasis gun just in case
oh oh all right they're gonna come out from the floors
aren't they oh i wonder what these little hatches are for oh
wow why are there little hatches underneath me i wonder
Oh, my God.
I'm trying.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It hits me.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Look at that.
Perfect dodge!
I'll just wait here.
There we go.
Easy.
You think I have self-heal, but I don't.
I have to live with that.
I'll hack the list if you're ready.
Because your ammo is full.
Oh, he's ready to hack?
Alright.
There we go.
Are we there yet?
Not sure.
See, I told you, hack is all I need.
The advancement is paying off, chat.
We should top up the facility.
Oh, there's a lot of guns here.
I wonder why.
I wonder why there's so much equipment over here.
Oh, man.
Oh, he was like, there might be a boss fight or something.
Nah, that can't be.
The game just felt very, very generous.
Yeah, I know I heal, but I keep thinking I would have, like,
recharge, you know?
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, after the fight is over, I just have passive regen or
some shit.
I didn't even play too much Overwatch.
I just, in my head, I was like, surely I'll have passive
regen if nobody touches me.
Lockdown disengaged.
Reconnecting primary power.
at 30%.
Ooh.
40%.
Yeah, I powered everything up.
Actually, that doesn't mean more robots are gonna start
spotting in now.
By powering up.
You're also powering up the 3D printers.
Severe in primary connection.
This is Edith.
Unregistered guests are forbidden from this area.
Oh.
It's just one guy.
right scanning don't worry i have hack targets identified
neutralizing threats
oh you're so friendly shade we're gonna have to fight our
way through very sound guide i don't know you said if the
sounds okay i wasn't paying i i was i was taking care of the
kid you would understand right wait what why did not let me
hack the fuck wait what the fuck oh my god oh my okay sorry
oh sorry like stuff was happening stuff was wait what why
can't i move wait why can't i run wait i can't hack Oh my
gosh!
Oh my gosh!
I was pressing Windows!
I was pressing Windows accidentally!
So, um, the reason why...
Oh, wait, it's up here.
My thumb was on Windows instead of like, actually...
Whoops.
You're going down.
okay I might actually need this
that was an oopsie on my part so you're like where's the
fucking shotgun told you all I need whoa okay
unleash a crew shot nearby when you're a down enemy oh nice
All right, here we go.
Wait, how do I know when it's down, though?
I just...
Oh, shit!
This ain't over yet.
There you go.
I'm trying!
There we go.
Oh, now that's when I know it's down.
It gives me a cutscene.
Oh, never mind.
I think it's because I did.
Don't be down, obvious.
what is she gonna do oh oh shit quick time event i was like
where is she oh what am i going to do when a hawker when you
use it opens nearby enemies and more the press x when the
it'll be hacking or how can i activate when used press x oh
my gosh she's alting whoa where did that come from there
you go hey who are you pushing around there we go
well oh shit there you go all
right i need to grab some guns real quick all right give me
a sec let me grab a stasis gun oh nice it's like really far
from me that's very convenient all right
I'm trying but he keeps turning around I want to he keeps
turning around all right critical oh wait he locked up
There we go.
So easy.
Look at that.
Easiest boss fight of my life.
Anyway, it's like now sound guy.
Now you can tell me if the sound's okay.
Now.
Now don't worry.
Now I'm free.
Playtime's over.
High five.
All right.
the AI more information right now my AI is learning look at
that she's real guys I told you she's real I told you she
was real I trained her to high five the boss fight is fun
though I really enjoy the the boss fight there shelter
access level unlocks new function oh I can do more in my
shelter Let's just take it back to the shelter.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I'm back now.
Wait, what the fuck?
It kicked me out.
A new destination has been added to the tram line.
The mass production array is now accessible.
Why did it take me back?
I wasn't done looting.
I wasn't done looting!
My loot!
and chibi-doki ai bonding lord kerosus thank you super chat
thank you thank you i was what
okay i hope i got everything i need i do not know i was like
in the middle of looting and it like took me it kicked me
out what is that thing i'm gonna get a better look wait i'm
waiting
cabin system hello oh my god oh that's a little guy a little
trinket so where you been all this time see you guys now
we're all robots are evil oh my god he's so cool he's so him
we wanted out the giant so cab what up a most pointed
inquiry let us say asleep but that device woke us up leaving
us available to offer you our wide range of invaluable
services wait what services shelter level upgraded central
terminals now loaded with shiny new stuff all right our em
replicator beta now online and ready to serve why they're
like my little butlers.
The shelter is equipped with a level system.
Deliver a shelter.
License key to cabin.
Increase the shelter's level and unlock additional
functions.
Okay.
What can you do?
Quick, do something.
Cabin system booting up.
Hello, fellow cradle crew.
Allow us to enhance your shelter life experience with our
newest service.
Okay.
Introducing cabin staff club exchange cabin coins to unlock
shelter surfaces a little quit pro coin Wait is paywall this
gratuity for first-time crew one i haven't coined
compliments of the wait the workers get paid It's like a
vending machine got paid to work here Our fine selection of
stamp boards what what am i gonna do with fucking stamps i
mean i'm on the moon That...
I got like a paddle pass.
The company pays me so I can spend money at the company.
Alright.
Walker data will be uploaded to the bot defense.
What?
I'm playing bingo?
Okay.
Can you earn money here?
Oh, it's mine's like a plea-pedia.
Bots deploy wouldn't create a detail after your scans or
designs.
Oh, so it's like if I want to know their weak points and
stuff, right?
All right, what do I unlock here?
Sector guard bot.
We are honored to provide one of our greatest credits, guys.
Manicon lied.
There is capitalism in space.
face.
See, they give the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't have bingo yet.
I have to pay for bingo.
Oh, is this music?
Oh, it is.
This is the jukebox.
Satisfaction level.
Maximum.
Glad we could be of assistance.
I need to pay bingo to...
I need to pay to play bingo.
for the chance to unlock more for my home.
Alright.
I like that they gave him a little cap and humanizes him a
little bit more.
They didn't gotcha game.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I just need three more.
I gotta save up.
I gotta save up for my kid.
Alright, so now it'll be printed.
that's a fucking lie oh there it is multi-hack okay we
actually need that
i was saying there has to be a multi-hack uh tool like
there's no way i can keep doing this one by one one put time
extended while damage printed and ready to use all right
critical shot and let me help slow a critical shot node oh
okay we need that for sure mod slot add extra slots to
accommodate multiple mods yep i'll grab that we need a new
mod we need two mods upgrade the gun after my kid is fully
upgraded will i upgrade the gun all
right we can go now uh i have two mods now so i can put the
multi-hack as well Oh, JK.
Never mind.
That's hacking nodes.
I already have multi-hack, honestly.
JK, I forgot this is...
Oops.
Oh, I need to talk to her a little bit.
Hello, little girl.
Hello, Diana.
What do you want to talk about?
Now we can head to the comms tower, right?
Yep.
It's in the mass production array.
talk long enough then i can finally call home i can finally
call an uber after that let's go what there it is there's
what what is it look this terminal has you can learn more
about the cradle's bots with this wasn't exactly dying to
find out what i think i already know that damn what the hell
was this so i thought you'd be interested all right I need
to what's her new I need a oh yeah how there has to be a
better way I don't like pressing the alt key for hacking is
there another can I really bind that I'm gonna do like I
want a mouse button I really hate the alt key placement
Let me
toggle.
Control button config.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, cool.
There's no way it's just four buttons.
Okay, alright, PC.
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, that does not make sense right now.
Oh, it does have my mouse button.
I didn't see that.
I didn't realize that was...
Okay, never mind.
That's actually a lot easier.
Now that I know.
It's just like, why is it four buttons?
Wait, auto-hacking?
I don't even need a hack.
There's lock-on?
What the fuck does it just have to do?
Was I just not reading?
Maybe.
To be fair, I did skip several...
Actually, I skipped several tutorials because I had to...
Because I was trying to adjust my volume.
Okay.
I mean, I don't even have to do the hacking.
That's fine.
Alright, we're done to go.
Give me a new loadout.
What the fuck?
How do you got unequipped in my gun?
Alright, ride the tram.
Let's go.
i'm having fun so far i really like i really like all the i
really like all the mechanics that they introduced uh but
yeah you guys want to check out the game please feel free to
click on the link pin in the chat and in the description
below uh we have a special promotion with msi right the
right now so thank you msi for the sponsor and if you stick
around by the end of the stream uh you uh you can
potentially win a free gift code or game code for pragmata
you can yourself too.
I fucking knew it.
Look at that.
That's called Gamer Instinct right there.
I was like, why is there a random hole here?
Map design.
Can't tell if we'll actually get through to Earth, but I
need to know about my team.
Look at that.
I knew it.
Instantly.
I recognize something was off.
all right oh hey there's a cat wait a hologram cat the
cat's not real diana i could just pull up a cat on my phone
what are you doing with it
oh oh shit okay i knew she wasn't guys i knew she'll be okay
It's like, remember that kid, the whole mechanic is based
off this kid?
Well, she's dead now.
Anyway, we're going to get rid of that mechanic.
You have to be more careful.
If something happened to you, I'd be in real trouble.
See, guys, I didn't lose the kid.
I mean, well, you best think on that yourself.
Now I'll never leave you alone ever again.
Yeah, ask for my permission.
You want to leave my room?
Leave the house.
That's true.
I think they're dead.
They're most likely dead.
Is it like a program?
Is it kind of like a video or some shit?
Because it's a fucking hologram.
Look at that.
Now she'll never get to leave the house and we're going to
have a curfew now.
That's her fault.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you can print a car.
Oh my god wait a minute I'm pretty sure they're dead in
space Oh what the fuck
Oh I shouldn't use those too I realize that's just a waste
of the link that's just a waste of a link are there any
shiny yellows anywhere Okay.
Alright.
What's this?
The mass production ring uses a massive limb replicator
installed in the ceiling to test print structures, capo
ships, and jumbo airliners.
Because the area will be sealed out by heavy bulkheads when
you hear an announcement, please evacuate the area
immediately.
Oh, does Scan get any items?
Two?
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
I need to make sure...
Oh, I keep forgetting not to use it.
Not to use the multiple thing.
That's for late.
Yeah, I was going to say it doesn't tell me...
Like, about the items.
I feel like it tells me, like, objectives, but not the
items.
During lunar exploration, the aura was discovered
accidentally through...
nanomachines refinement it yielded luna filament a material
capable of replicating structural and functional data uh
research at the cradle is exploring its applications uh with
expectation to drive significant growth and breakthrough for
delphi all right everything seems to be going okay i hope i
mean filament who names these things oh yeah actually i need
to oh i thought that was i got a little paranoid there am i
supposed to go oh this is new i'm playing pragmata right now
we're having the stream playing the background i love this
game so much oh right thank you for the super chat thank you
yeah i'm having a lot of fun too inquiry keyword pragmata is
classified security level only a summary is available for
viewing a high functioning on autonomous prosthetic body
with a simulated organic structure currently undergoing
operational testing in limited sectors due to differing
design concept is not compatible with standard workbots
commonly used throughout the cradle i was i was a little
worried about it because like the trailers were you know
like you it's hard to tell you know with the trailers oh my
god i'm printing a car they don't i can make
people back home have only heard about stuff like this cause
the trailer didn't really I don't know the trailer wasn't
like I don't want to say like bad but it just seemed like
you know it's not it didn't seem like oh a really really
really good game but then I'm glad to be proven wrong
because it seems like you know I've been joining a lot yeah
the trailer didn't sell it very well I a lot, yeah, there
was a lot of trailers for this game as well.
So I was just like, it was hard to see if this game was
gonna be good or not.
Especially because it's a new IP as well.
Yeah, it's something you have to play to actually like,
enjoy it.
Yeah, it didn't look very hype.
Yeah, that's a better way.
Just didn't look very hype, and it didn't really sell the
game very well.
So I was like a little skeptical, but I'm glad to be proven
wrong.
Yeah, you gotta play it to actually like Like, you know.
And, like, the hacking mechanic, too.
Like, the hacking mechanic wasn't really shown very well in
the trailer.
That's how they feel is Dan's, Dan's hacking gauge.
Oh.
Where?
There it is.
That big one.
Right in the middle.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
Look at that.
New Moon City.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
What the fuck?
You can print New York?
They printed New York City?
Okay, yeah.
The way they were printing cars.
Oh my god, when they said you can print anything.
Like, all three of New York on the moon.
Bro, you can't print anything.
Bro, I can make a city.
I can make my own.
You won't download a city, would you?
Oh my god, there's a fucking office.
Yeah, the taxis.
Oh, okay.
I think the 3D print did go walk you there, though, I will
say.
It got a little inception-y there in the middle of the 3D
print.
Okay, wait, I'll go this way.
Probably a cleaner than New York, unironically.
Thank you for the super chat, Lord Gross.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah, something definitely gonna come.
I don't trust, like, these vent areas.
Alright.
Oh, there it is.
There must be an upgrade where I can scan for...
Oh, my God.
Even the robots, they're like, New York City!
Okay, now I grab the shinies.
Oh, oh, there we go.
Now we're talking.
Oh, reloading.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why was he, like, trying to link to me?
You guys see that?
I was very confused.
What was that line?
thing on me.
Like, he tethered to me for some reason.
I'm being a little bit hordy right now because, like, I
don't want to waste my shotgun for these little guys.
I don't know.
It just doesn't seem worth it.
Oh, they have a grab?
Okay.
Because I was, like, confused there.
I was confused a little bit why he, like, just had, like,
something tethered to me.
You're going down.
Is that it?
Okay.
Can't access anything yet.
I don't know, it goes there.
But I'm trying to make sure I'm not missing anything.
He's trying to get me.
I'm gonna get you.
Oh, I can't hack this yet.
Oh?
Oh, shit it's a lockdown
hello oh hi hey it is oh yeah they're like 50 oh there's the
firewall so that's how it is edis isn't very nice is it oh
shit sorry oh wait she does have hp
the HP.
I don't know.
Try scanning.
I'm scanning.
Okay, there it is.
Okay, now I realize she does have health.
Oh, is that the up?
Oh, it's up.
Oh.
Oh, I don't.
Oh, oh, no, oh,
oh, oh, oh, what the, oh,
I do not fuck with that.
Hmm, what the hell?
I'm gonna go back.
Uh, yeah, I have...
I can't upgrade her.
They're just as badass you think they are.
I was like, no, please put that face back on.
Sir.
You, you okay?
Yeah.
I just saw a fucking abomination.
A freak of nature.
But yeah, I'm fine.
Alright.
We're almost Son, yes.
She's almost maxed out.
Almost got the firmware.
Fully upgraded.
What even is this?
When hacking gauges full, press X.
Oh, wait.
That's the okay.
Build up from completed task.
We actually need these two.
Node slot.
And we need a node slot too.
Alright.
All in.
I don't need gun upgrades.
I just need Diana upgrades.
Wait.
Wait, when did we get this?
Since we printed the globe.
We both appeared at the same time.
I see.
Looks like we got some freebies.
Freebies?
The person who made that REM put in a little extra to cheer
us up.
Oh, let's buy one, get one free.
Tell the person who made it that I liked it a lot.
I made it.
I'm sure they got the message.
Yay!
Aw.
Having good time.
I'm such a good parent.
I told you guys.
Alright, let's see.
I'm going to equip anything.
I'm unfulfilled slot.
I'm still going to put the multi-hack.
It's going to pay out eventually.
all right you made this i made this i did i literally
printed it i i uploaded it onto the computer and i pressed
print i practically did all the hard work needed it was so
hard pressing those two buttons then make a game so there
has to be some sort of hour aspect that's true all right
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Can't hack this yet.
All right.
Shockwave gun.
I'm going to bring this gun out real quick just in case.
Oh.
All right.
There's three little vents in here.
Hmm.
Oh.
New gun.
That blast damage and knock back enemies.
Briefly downing flows for a follow-up attack.
Or a hack.
Okay, what does this look like?
Oh, okay, it's a grenade launcher.
Alright.
I guess I'll try it out.
Reloading?
Easy.
There we go.
I don't even know.
Oh!
Alright.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, I thought there was more than one.
I was gonna say, I don't know about this gun.
That's what the third hole was for.
I was like, where's the third hole?
Let's see.
One over here.
This one would be fun.
Yeah, this is...
Uh...
Redgate Key.
Yeah.
There's also a ton of stuff you can't find.
Aww.
Oops.
It's definitely a lot cleaner.
Alright, now we're down.
We're up here now.
Oh, shit!
Oh, I did not.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Give me a sec.
I need- Oh!
Oh!
How do I cancel that?
I do not remember.
Oh, I can read.
Okay, give me a...
Alright, here we go.
I can redo this.
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a...
There we go.
Sorry, I had to figure that out real quick.
I'm trying.
Yeah, let's do this.
Look out.
Alright.
Oh, I did not mean to do the multi.
I was doing it too fast.
Ooh, that was a little awkward.
That's alright.
Zero damage, zero hit run.
Oh, they're mannequins.
This, it's a mannequin.
They're made to look like humans to show off clothes and
stuff.
They might look apart, but real people got that life blood
in them real people have eyes no blood means no moving no uh
humans got a certain warmth to them oh oh oh over 36 degrees
celsius there's a beacon it's so close come on it's got to
be another way oh i already have the hacking gauge hat oh
nice wait excuse me oh my god can i i have hands oh my god
to do a little part i can do that apparently
all right i just slowly hover over it
oh oh oh oh oh okay right on okay those lasers should hurt
him as well it's like the hidden third option oh my god it
was glass all long.
I was like, surprise, bitch!
Okay, unlock banana.
Open enemies to expose for 15% longer.
Oh, I like that.
I have a mod spot for it, anyway.
Alright, open sesame.
Oh.
Okay.
How do I get cake?
Alright.
Oh, okay, nice.
I can't reach this.
The glass got it.
How can I get down?
It's like closed up.
Like, like you can't, there's no good reflection.
I don't know what space glass looked like.
I hear it.
No.
Here you are.
I've never worked a space glass before.
Wait, how do I...
How are we gonna reach that beacon?
There's no clear way through.
The only choice is up.
I don't...
I don't know which way I should go.
Like...
Oh, that's a lot of them.
Nice.
That's right!
Dodge!
Oh, okay, it was not a dodge.
It was...
I was very confident in that I dodged that.
Alright, open sesame.
Yeah, maybe we can upgrade our stuff.
I was like, look at that.
Look at that dodge.
Okay, there's nothing here.
God, I can't wait for the upgrade.
That shows me items.
Okay, nice!
Upgrade!
Yippee!
Got my upgrade!
Actually, we needed more of that.
Oh, shit!
Hover?
I'll grab the multi.
I feel like... I feel like we're gonna need that.
Yeah, there's... Oh, yeah, there's four... Yeah, there's...
Yeah
Yeah There you go You know what overdrive fuck it there's
way too many people here There's way too many people What do
you mean I thought I also
Okay All right, nice
Oh my god, I'm still reloading!
Alright, it's fine.
Here we go.
Yeah, I also the wrong way.
I thought it was like...
I didn't realize I had to look...
It's like visual.
I thought it was...
Proximity and not like...
LOS.
Now I know.
nope guys maybe I should have upgraded my gun it's just just
a maybe oh whoops oh she's fine oh she's fine
I thought it was aoe not LOS all at once
all right standing here feels just like being on earth it's
as if the New York I saw as a child is right before my eyes.
It's not just about meeting the basic conditions for life.
We humans need landscapes that can hold our memories.
Places to call home.
Luna filament can recreate those memories for us.
It could say, oh my god, that's what I, sorry, it just
clicked in my head that it's a filament, as in like 3D
printer filament, but made of the moon.
It's just, sorry, it just clicked in my head.
Oh my god, the Luna it pettogey this person really felt like
they were on her but it's not for me game doesn't
necessarily look like the moon but i don't know okay pure
lunaman lunum my mind is blown purity chunk of lunum keep up
upgrading equipment to a high level then oh my god oh my god
i have a new firmware update and that means i can upgrade my
child even more okay i should actually start upgrading my
gun i should
the german child dragon stokey will protect you if you help
her survive exactly see if you're useful where'd the wall go
it was just a hologram
hologram was a big stuffy company, but I quickly found out.
Also, Carl, they gave me the super chat.
Thank you.
That everyone here is a massive weirdo.
I guess that just means I'm in a good company.
That's exactly why I've always wanted to work here.
Though no one's breathing down my neck.
No pressure to conform.
Just pure creative freedom.
I even got the chance to dig into Credo's design history.
Turns out each sector was assigned to a different
contractor, and they all let their AIs run wild, however
they pleased.
uh of that the hallway trams and sector layouts are messed
up it's inconvenient to get anywhere around here without
directions from the ai in charge i probably end up wandering
around the last three days but that's the best part it's a
hundred times more exciting during typical nine to five
office space plus i love that i can make my own little
hideouts too wow this company has everything stasis net
we'll just use stasis net they didn't give it to us it might
mean it's important.
Usually that's how it goes.
Oh, that's a lot of MZ.
Yep.
Oh.
Oh, whoop.
Oh, yeah, there's a lot more.
I mean...
Oh, shit!
QQQQQQQQQQQ.
Oh, man.
I wish I had my multi-hack.
really do it right now.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'll find him.
Now it's my turn.
There we go.
All right, we definitely need to make another heal.
Oh, now.
Okay.
All right.
That's all right.
I need it now.
Now I have the multi-ack.
That's alright.
I'm fully healed now.
Alright.
We'll grab this and...
This has more ammo.
Damn.
That was that guy's fucking 401k.
It's like fully guarded and everything.
Earth really look like this you've really been left in the
dark.
Yeah, we definitely have our boxes on the walls I was left
in sleep mode for so the vault was all messed up.
Uh-huh There was no one else.
No, there's a rem here This is a parkour area Yeah Just
gotta make sure Is it not?
Is there another way over?
But this felt so parkourable.
Why would they put all these boxes here if it's not for me
to parkour?
This is false information.
Oh my god.
It was a bait.
He fucking baited me with all these boxes.
Oh my god.
That actually looked like a...
true why not parkour if parkour exactly that's what i'm
saying there's no way there is no way there is no way this
is not parkourable why did you put all these boxes here
because it makes sense
what's the point of map design if i can't be the sign
Okay.
And that means there's something...
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
That's right.
You can't hide from me.
That's fucking right.
You were not friend-shaped.
Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
There we go.
I made it just in.
time yeah i thought he was so slick it got more coins oh
there it is got my rem oh my god she's gonna she's gonna be
a baller adventure for our kinds kiki bikes and it'll roll
forever is that another rem sure is got another rem let's
take it back to the shelter
I see you.
Let me hack you.
There you are.
Oh, fuck.
Don't say it.
I had a feeling.
The moment he said, is that it?
Always.
It's the moment he said that.
I was like, there's another one.
Isn't there?
That clicker.
almost got me he was like that's not it you almost got me
i'll have to say that you almost got me there
a lot of loot those corridors here's attack power but 10
when within 10 meters of the enemy I wonder what weapons
that have worked with.
This project route recreates iconic cityscapes from major
cities that is New York, Seoul, Madrid, and Delhi is an
unpercented large-scale output test.
At the same time, it aims to prove that lunar filament can
enable rapid urban development, showcasing its values on
Earth and paving the way for future projects.
Oh my god, are we going to go to Seoul?
Is that the next one?
Is there anything over here?
Yeah.
Alright, another one down.
Oh?
Yay!
Oh, nice.
There's a replicator there, too.
That's actually very convenient.
Can I jump through this?
No.
I swear I can climb through there.
I have arms.
Like, I could just...
Climb through this.
I don't need you crawling off the side of a bridge going
after it again.
Got it?
I won't do that again.
We can upgrade now.
Ooh, I have a lot of upgrades.
Sorry, little girl.
It's upgrade time.
Upgrade over dialogue.
Alright.
Nice.
I upgrade first.
Please be patient.
it.
Nice!
Alright, we did it!
Wait, I can...
Alright, now, I guess I'll go...
I'll upgrade the guns now.
All in.
Plan is working.
Okay, inventory has been added.
Riot Blaster.
Critical shot.
I need a critical shot.
Yeah, this.
Yeah, your present can win.
I gotta upgrade.
We need...
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Unupgrade to enhance when the hacking gauge is full.
Press X to activate.
Sun time.
Oh, it's perform...
Oh, we already have this.
Hack engage.
King.
I'll increase the...
Okay.
How much do I have?
a thousand seven oh one crease the gauge so repair uh should
we do shock wave or I feel do the shock wave the shotgun has
been really good so far how do I like the game um it's been
pretty fun I'm actually enjoying it a lot more thrusters Oh,
I didn't even...
Right before it...
Oh, the temporary...
Oh, I should have got that.
Oh, that seemed very important.
Oh, I should have read that before I upgraded everything.
Alright.
Critical builds are pretty meta.
Well, let chat decide the next upgrade after...
During the next run.
Alright.
Here, have a basketball.
That's right.
Now my daughter's...
Holy shit!
I thought...
Oh my...
Okay, that...
I did not realize how tall this fucking thing is.
Oh...
Thanks for talking to me all the time.
Look at that.
Oh!
It's supposed to be when we first...
She made AI art.
How dare you?
Do you know how...
Oh my god.
You wrote your name, too.
I got AI art.
guys oh my gosh she knows how to spell dude ai slopp she
that my ai made it it made it at crock can you at diana pt
can you make a make a picture of us two together don't get
it the only acceptable form of ai all right all right play
basket Oh, wait, that's not it.
It's time to play basketball.
Bee ball time.
The basketball.
Man, I got you.
This is way too tall for her.
I better seize her dunking.
I can't push her.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
Basketball.
Oh, she plays with the Oorto.
She plays with the globe and Not the fucking basketball net
I set up for her.
She'll never be balled.
I got her a new toy and she doesn't want to use it.
This is what being a parent is like.
Oh my god, please.
Just, I just want to see if you can shoot the hoop.
We don't have...
There's like five different balls.
Wouldn't it be fun if there were replicator bridges
everywhere?
That's how you end up with more bridges than roads.
I guess they're fun because they're special.
She'll walk over there, right?
Oh yeah, I also have a new bingo.
Bingo time!
Alright.
Look at down here.
Pass through.
Yay!
Bingo!
Designed to protect and carry repair carriages.
You can hold it as one.
Oh, nice.
I have two now.
Oh, yes.
This is one of our more popular items.
All right.
For your patronage.
No problem.
All right.
All right, Diana.
You play with the basketball now?
Diana?
My dad, new toy.
New toy, Diana.
Where the fuck did the kid go?
There she is.
Oh, I don't know.
She's going to loop.
She's going to see it.
Look at that.
Of course, of course she...
Don't worry.
She's coming back.
That's just going to see...
Oh, she's running.
She saw it, right?
She saw it.
She's going to run over.
There, you see it, right?
You see the basketball?
Yeah.
Diana.
That...
You didn't even touch the toy.
My daughter will be a basketball player if it's the last day
I do.
It's like that.
What was it?
It's like that American Olympic skater where, like, she was
clearly very talented.
ice skater and her dad made her ice skate like she made her
ice skate 24 7 that she literally won a medal and was like
i'm done dad i'm like i quit like i cannot i cannot do this
anymore
damn come on you're gonna be a basketball player if it's the
last thing we do oh hey there's my ai art
yeah and then it like like she was like I forgot her name.
It starts, uh, but she was like, yeah, yeah, Alyssa, Alyssa,
yeah, and she was like, very, very, she was clearly, like,
super gifted, but now, like, but now she's like, she
basically was like, I hate ice skating, but now she, I heard
she's, like, back, she, like, came back to ice skating on a
condition that, like, her dad has zero involvement with,
like, any, like, with any of her ice skating career, like,
in her ice skating career.
Uh, I'll grab that, because I'm always, I feel like I'm
always close quarters.
yeah yeah like she gets to decide her whole like she gets to
decide the routine um and like like like everything
basically and like her practices and like coaches and stuff
yeah she thought she hated the sport but it's only because
her dad like made her hate the sport
I guess we go this way.
The elevator is not on?
Like, it's glowing.
I guess not.
I don't have to go down.
I guess the elevator is not working.
Oh, the elevator goes down.
That makes more sense.
Oh, it's...
Oh, it's new.
What's this?
The fire's armor piercing rounds when charged.
Is power and piercing effects dramatically unaffected by
range?
It excels.
Oh, it's a sniper.
Oh, shit.
Wait, does it collapse?
It collapse.
Like, I just upgraded the shotgun.
That's not fair.
I literally just upgraded the shotgun.
Okay.
I'll have to try this out now.
I do have the multi-tool already.
Uh...
This is
my turn.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's crazy.
Oh, that's not what I wanted.
I wanted to kill it.
Whoops!
I have to line it up perfectly.
though which might be the hard part oh shit okay there you
go
oh my god that did nothing that did nothing okay that's fine
there's a sensitive oh there it is that makes sense what the
what the fuck
oh I do not like that that's right get dodge okay now they
have shields against hacking all right a new thing to worry
about now.
Can't hack when it glows red.
When red equals bad.
Multi-hack.
I have healers.
Alright.
Is there any yellow stuff?
I get parkour.
Wait, there is a parkour, but how do I get there?
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
How do I... Okay.
Clearly I have to parkour up here somehow.
I assume is for later.
Oh, I already have ammo for that.
Oh, later as in now.
Now is later.
Now equals later, guys.
Wait, what the fuck is this?
What?
Alright, buddy.
It's fine.
Just a little bit of...
Oh, increases hacking range by 30%.
Okay, I actually really need that.
I'm just gonna...
I'll heal now.
And then just grab this.
Fuck it.
I thought that was heals.
What the fuck did I grab?
I...
Alright, that's...
Alright, that's not gonna hurt me later on down the line.
What...
What did I grab?
That was great.
What did I lose one of my heals?
I thought I healed.
Everything will be fine, surely.
That's a problem for future, Doki.
Oh, yeah, I was going to say, is green not a heal?
What the fuck did I grab?
Yeah, but I lost one of my heal thingies.
I thought it, like, replenishes it or something.
But it didn't replenish.
There's a parkour segment here.
I don't want to go down yet.
Down seems very dangerous.
There you go.
Yeah, down.
Down seems to be a problem.
I mean, I'm trying to hack right now.
There you go.
Oh
Grab the multi-hack Just in case
Probably a lot of stuff down.
No, it does seem like there's a lot of loot down there.
I just Don't really want to deal with that right now.
All right Might be time to go down.
Oh, wait, no, but there's loot over here, though could go
down i could also grab loot
oh elevators here
all right
guys that's a way wait i can figure this out oh that's a lot
of enemies I go right here
All right, maybe I can Oh shit Oh shit Oh my god, I did not
Oh my god, dodge I can't dodge it There we go, there we go
All right.
We're fine.
Oh, shit.
How did he get up here?
Who did I link, though?
All right, there we go.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
It's fine.
See, everything is fine.
What's that?
Oh, my God.
What is that?
What?
Oh my god.
What is that?
Holy shit, he's so fast.
Stop!
In the name of the law!
Oh no, he's disappeared.
No!
He's so fast!
I thought it was like, like the spiral thing.
Where they, I didn't, if I knew, I thought it was like,
where, okay, now I know.
Where, like, you chase it around type deal.
I didn't realize he actually fucking leaves.
I wonder what weapons that would work with.
Okay, now I know he fucking pieces out.
I was close to, oh my god, I was actually really close to
grabbing him too.
I'm not in.
I was literally like three more to go
Yeah, but I have to go back down here And the enemies
respond too I don't know if I want to Deal with that I could
have caught it but In my head I thought it was like spiral
brain Like spiral mechanic when you're chasing the egg Um
You know when you're chasing the egg And then you just run
around it That's what I thought was going to happen.
I thought I was just chasing the egg.
I didn't realize it actually can disappear.
Because I could have just went around.
I could have easily just went around.
I don't even...
I could have ulted.
I could have ulted that guy, right?
Oh, nice.
I got a slide.
Yay!
But that doesn't make it less...
It all served as a...
secret hide-up.
Yeah, another run.
Oh, I thought there'd be a hide-up here.
It was very hide-up-coded.
Okay.
Probably go this way.
We gotta slide.
Whoppy.
Okay.
Then we gotta go...
Okay, we gotta do the parkour.
again.
That recharged.
Alright, up we go.
Oh, wait, no.
It was this way.
Alright.
Now, up we go.
Yay!
Riot Blaster.
I don't know if I'd like the Stasis now to riot more.
Which is better, guys.
Oh.
Do humans really need to eat more than lunch today?
Your energy efficiency doesn't seem good.
Sure, that's fair.
But sharing a meal is more than just recharging.
I was an orphan.
So at dinner with my new family, just having someone that
was someone who was magical.
She's an orphan too.
We're trauma bonding.
Talking with someone who just accepts you for you is a kind
of nourishment.
Aw, we're bonding, guys.
For your soul.
You can get nutrients from talking?
That's all she fucking...
She's just like me.
Like father, like daughter.
That's all she absorbed in that conversation.
She's like, oh my god.
Who cares about the fact that you were an orphan?
You can't get nutrients from talking?
Oh, that...
One, two, three, four, two, four, six, eight.
Whoa, who do we appreciate?
We might have to...
Does it work?
Nice.
I'll just get rid of them.
All right.
What the fuck is that?
Oh!
The critical!
That's what it is.
There we go.
I'll just do it now.
That is easy.
I don't think I actually needed a critical for that.
It was like, he was like one HP, not gonna lie.
Alright, something's gonna come out of here.
Oh
God Okay, oh
my god Get over here This is my turn
Okay.
Oh my god, he can jump!
He can jump!
Guys, he can jump!
Alright.
It's fine.
Oh shit!
Oh shit, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal!
Something's aiming at us!
Yeah, I know!
He'll heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal,
heal.
There we go.
all right oh my gosh it's okay it's okay everything is fine
it's okay it's a little merry-go-round too close it's a
little my little merry-go-round all right that should kill
it soon
Oh my god.
He fell down.
Quick.
He can't move.
Help by Fallen.
Oh my god.
He's so fucking tanky.
It's my, to be fair, it's a little bit my fault because I
did not upgrade any of my default gun.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
We live.
I did it.
Maybe hacking is...
Maybe all in on the hacking is not it.
Maybe...
I might have messed up on that.
More to go.
We can do this, Hugh.
Gotten.
Having fun?
Yeah.
Let's see.
Grab the multi.
Oh!
Thank God.
the okay never mind the riot blaster is i think the riot
blaster is better now now i know now i know all right i have
upgrades for this at least
yeah we're gonna do next we're gonna create brooklyn or
detroit how about something oh tokyo what about something in
the Oh, they were very homesick.
Nothing but wood.
You'd need wooden samples at least a hundred years old for
something that strong.
A worthy challenge.
But we can we like print a deer?
I mean, we could print anything, right?
So we should be able to print like a deer or something.
Yay!
Oh, that, we can upgrade her.
Oh, I can get more the hack stuff.
Okay, we'll grab this and go back to upgrade.
Alright.
Yeah, pure Lunum.
Alright, let's go upgrade our gun and
actually multiple guns, too.
If I could print a girl, a little girl, I could surely print
some animals, too.
Like, why do I only have a hologram of a cat?
Alright, play You do not get any gifts until you play the
basketball.
That's right.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Diana, that thing.
Ah, the ball's rolling away.
Yeah, that thing.
Diana, we're not getting any new toys until you play with
the last toy I bought you.
Somehow it rolls off.
She's gonna be a basketball player, whether she likes it or
not.
That's just what it wants.
Sometimes toys and books just pull your strings like that.
Pull my strings?
How?
Yeah.
Beats me.
Maybe they don't like being left alone.
I swear to God that if you go back to the goddamn globe, I
swear to God.
Like what?
Let me show you how this works I swear to God, Diana If you
I swear
Doesn't matter how many toys I get it It's always that one
Back to the globe
Technically she's a baller That is round shape That is ball
shape to keep All right, I got that.
I need to upgrade it.
There was one I wanted to get.
All right, the charge pierce apparently is really a sub.
Yeah, you're gonna get that.
Hello, dragon is from the Pragmata speedrunning community.
Protect the globe.
Addy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, and then we wanted to know it's live.
So then we have more stuff like that.
All right, we definitely need...
Uh, mod slot, I could grab another, wait, how much should I
have?
Grab this.
Oh, I should, I keep forgetting about that one.
Um, and then I'll upgrade the charge piercer, because he
seems really strong, and I should most definitely download
the riot blaster.
Yeah.
I'll get, I forgot about the thruster thing.
Yeah, thruster might have been.
been the thruster might have been should have been the first
thing i got oops oopsie we're not giving diana any of the
new toys until she plays that the fucking basketball oh oh
my gosh she's doing it guys guys i told you guys you all
doubted me you all look at that look at i knew it look at
that
Look at that, I knew it, I knew she was meant to be a
basketball player.
Look at the strength on those arms.
She did it.
Um, you probably feel lonely or just uneasy.
Might even start losing faith.
I'm so proud of her.
She's bawling.
She's actually bawling.
I've seen enough put her in the Lakers.
I've got you to talk to so I'll probably be fine Oh my god
LeBron James It's quiet right now He's so quiet now I wonder
why He brought no new toys Oh she played boss She played
boss Should I climb up it?
Yes Go climb up the slide why
it's too small for you oh that's cute this is made for for
you just for you yeah oh and you play on this multiple times
I see how it oh oh I see
that toy interests you oh she can climb up I used to do that
a lot too.
And then another kid would go down the slide and then we
hurt, we injure each other.
Remember the metal slides, the death traps?
Before they, before adults realized that like, realized
about child safety and the slides were made out of metal.
Like, good old times, you know, where it was actually
survival of the fittest.
Yeah, yeah.
The child skillets.
Yeah But you could go so fast.
That's true.
The wind feels so nice when I was sliding I wish I could go
faster.
They're so boring now Nope, not happening.
These things aren't toys Geez, I was only joking.
I know that Not so sure about that after your track record
with cats.
Oh my god.
I'm still bringing up the cats that one time Oh my god.
I lost my passport on the plane one time.
And then my mom never trusted me after that.
She's like, remember that time you lost your passport on the
plane.
Because you forgot to bring the, you left your passport on
the seat.
Do you remember that?
And it's like, mom, it's been eight years, mom.
I was a child.
It's been never...
again okay i'm gonna use the bathtub we're back guys i'll be
back
i am back uh alan bite size uh nsd smoky wb miller meddy
solid thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm
having a lot of fun uh with this game that's right see you
good oh we have bingo bingo let's grab some bingo real quick
damage against down or immobilize enemies oh the sheet
fucking slammed oh my god I swear to god
there's no way I missed that There's no fucking way I missed
the slam dunk Okay Um Go on the riot blaster and the charge
piercer right The charge piercer is better Like you guys
said Oh I don't have this I just realized I never made one
Oh my god Increases hacking range Okay apparently the
hacking range is really good Um Close quarters.
Against Downed or Immobilized Enemy.
I feel like we'll do this for now.
Is it, which one?
Which one's better?
The shotgun or the charge?
One of the few.
I like shotgun more personally.
We'll try.
Okay.
We're going to try.
Let's try range more.
And then we'll do this one.
I'll try it out.
Because if I have long-range hacking, then it should be
fine, right?
Alright, off to the next one.
Oh, do I have one?
No, that's because I don't have... I didn't print it.
Can I proceed to it?
Shotgun is big.
Alright, we'll try one run with the charge rifle, because I
do have a longer hacking range now, so it could...
You know, it could work out.
the end you know can't be too bad this way yeah it is there
anything here though okay this is where i came from ah okay
that does seem very dangerous all
right what's up here though oh all right another one done
there's a cat down there the last time we saw a cat she
almost died
here is that lead alright another bridge oh that's a lot of
enemies alright let's let us see what's down there let us
can't be that bad I can't let me back up, right?
There's no elevator.
Hmm.
There is money, though.
Okay.
All right.
Doesn't seem too bad right now.
there is a red door here I should be able to open this too
this area is extremely dangerous what the fuck is this oh I
can't go back oh
oh oh oh fuck okay oh
Oh Oh shit, oh shit, okay We'll just we'll just let that
happen
You know when they said it was really dangerous I understand
that what the fuck Oh shit, what do you mean I hit me?
Okay.
All right, there we go.
I don't think that was it.
The music is still going on.
Where's my range?
Where is this range that I was told of?
There we go.
you.
Alright, another one down.
Okay, there's a charge right here.
Alright, I might need to use Q.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot this is also the thing, too.
That's five?
That's so healthy.
I'm so healthy right now.
Alright, hack time!
Hack!
Alt!
Oh my god.
I wish I had more more ammo for this.
Oh god.
Oh!
No!
Heal, heal, heal, heal.
Heal, heal.
Oh, God.
I'm trying to!
Woo!
Oh my God, that's a critical.
That's a critical.
Take this.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
We're so fine.
Oh, you like this.
There you go.
And another one.
Keep hacking!
Diana!
All right.
We're almost there.
Oh, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Oh, my God.
Just keep on hacking.
Oh!
Not even close.
So easy!
Easiest challenge room of my fucking life!
Alright, 10% more Luna filament.
That's good.
Oh, we did it.
First try.
That's everything, right?
There's nothing more here.
Alright, more stuff on the back left.
Is there?
I don't see anything else.
That's everything.
My scan does not give me much.
My scan is literally just...
Here's the objective.
Unless there's like a secret room.
I don't think there is more stuff unless...
I'm blind.
That should be everything, right?
I'm leaving!
I hope to God that was everything!
Alright.
All clear, that's good to know.
Oh, there's more stuff here.
Nice.
We're a filament to print.
Yeah, what is that?
Archer's holder?
Okay, nice.
We actually need more heals.
Actually, do need this, too.
Oh.
Oh, oh, parkour.
Wait, okay, but there was something over here.
Was it not?
Yeah.
Oh, it's a taxi.
Is this lunar filament?
I don't think so.
Its basic compositional structure seems a bit odd.
It's corrupted.
It's all messed up.
Like it's glitched out or something.
Yeah, it's like corrupted.
Oh, that's what she was talking about.
Okay, we gotta go back on the elevator though.
Okay, we gotta do this again.
And now...
Alright, up we go.
Oh, now I'm back here.
Nice.
This is this way?
No, it was this way.
I came from there, so I have to go this way now.
Where is that ladder?
No, I came from here, so it's...
It's all blurring together.
Chat.
Everything is blurring together.
No, we already saw that dialogue.
It's the one where he's like, what do we do next?
And then she was like, why don't we make Japan?
And then it's like, can we do that, though?
We'll go this way.
Yeah, we already been here.
I need, like, a mini-map.
I'm so bad with this.
Like, something out of an amusement park here.
Uh, where?
I'll tell you later.
Go down?
We just go down?
Wait, that's new.
Oh, I don't know if I should risk it.
Do I have that already?
Guys, do I have that item already over there?
So I go down there.
How do I go back up?
What the loot?
I know I'm like debating.
If I go down here.
Let's find out.
You're right.
Why did I do that?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
The elevator.
Take the elevator.
Take the...
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
Alright.
Round two.
That's okay.
He doesn't know.
He's so confused.
Okay, now that I know...
There we go.
We figured it out.
Yeah.
Upgrade.
Okay, we needed that.
Oh, plus two?
That's so good for us.
Wait, what's over here?
All right, up I go.
Another up.
Thank goodness, I know, right?
I'm so happy.
There's... Thank God I have the aerodynamic shoes.
I actually need a healer.
I just noticed my HP.
Okay, now I'll just go here.
I just realized I don't go here.
I'm supposed to...
Where am I?
What?
This bridge leads to nowhere.
Where does this bridge lead to?
Do I go...
There?
Was that actually the correct way?
Just go this way?
Have I been here before?
I have...
No, I haven't.
Alright.
Nice.
Look at that.
See, I'm not that directionally challenged.
Oh, new.
Decoy generator?
That creates a lifelad and holograms drop for a short
period.
Oh, okay.
God, they're so stupid.
lots 100% of the time okay but where yeah we'll grab this I
don't like that the yellow glowing thing I'm sorry I just
didn't know what that was I that might have been a waste but
you don't understand what was that
all right there you go
oh what the fuck did that hurt me i couldn't tell
all right oh my god it's still he's still alive there you go
actually we'll do that and then i'll just shoot him shooting
him.
He'll die eventually.
And then, one more decore just to be safe.
Why?
He's 5?
Look at him.
So stupid.
Oh my god, I need to reload.
Keep hacking, Diana!
That's right, crush that decore!
Okay, we actually need more ammo.
What is this yellow thing?
That's gonna start crushing, right?
I
feel like that's gonna start crushing me.
Oh, there it is.
Never...
Oh!
Alright, let's find the...
Oh.
Next time!
That...
Oh, that definitely would have been...
been very helpful they finally granted me level five access
at last i i can dig into the red to the read earth memory
data that's still in development take i got s for style
though guys yeah but like i used up all i i was practicing
my weapon util, guys.
I have to practice weapon swapping.
You don't understand.
If my boss ever finds out, I'll never hear the end of it.
So I tucked the eminence behind my usual wall, and they do
catch me.
Well, I owe up and apologize.
Curiosity has price.
Turns out, Rems don't simply mimic materials.
They're perfect imitations.
Holy shit.
The Lunafilm is that good?
The accuracy of paintings and art pieces I printed.
Oh my god, you won't print a Mona Lisa, would you?
The really amazing little thing.
Still, even though scanning technology has improved, you
still need supplementary data to precisely replicate the
internal structures.
A question is, how is Delphi acquiring this information?
Well, I'm sure I'll find out soon enough.
Did you know that like, um, it's so hard to do art forging
now?
Because ever since the nuclear bomb, every, like, like pig
or something like regarding pigments or something for oil
painting contains like traces of like uh like uh what's it
called like the nuclear residue of a nuclear bomb so like
you can't forge something perfectly because older paintings
wouldn't contain that the radio carbon yeah so now for like
art forgery is a lot harder now from the radiation yeah so
like people would be It's clearly fake.
It has fake.
It has radiation in it.
That's pretty interesting.
A Centrio TV designed for transmitting sound and images also
serves as a stylish decor.
Oh my god, we're gonna fight.
Finally, I can brain rot the child.
The only way out is down.
Oh no.
Not.
Oh, I mean, I can do this.
Wee.
Oh.
I had a feeling this would happen.
Yeah.
Did you don't?
Did you really?
Oh
my god, I'm just gonna keep doing that.
Alright, it's fine.
I have another rocket blaster.
Boom!
You see?
See, guys?
Because of the earlier room, I was able to utilize my weapon
swaps.
I was able to utilize the weapon sauce more efficiently
because of all the practice I had earlier.
I didn't already have that.
I'll heal up too, just in case.
Wait, whoops.
Alright, let's go.
Oh.
I hear you.
I see you.
There you are.
Oh!
you he complimented me all right we don't do that yet
eventually be able to delete these oh that means i have to
god damn it that means i have to backtrack oh happy birthday
thomas happy second birthday on the moon my love did you
make another one of those fake cakes with a food replicator
like last year i can't wait until next year when can you
finally celebrate your birthday together months until we're
back in each other's arms.
I'm so proud of you, honey.
I love you.
Coco says she can't wait to see you.
Meow.
You're a beautiful wife.
Kristen.
I sure hope Thomas is okay.
Party, huh?
Why do humans celebrate getting older?
Life's worth celebrating.
Every new year is another gift.
Wait, that's a human.
Wait, that is not a human.
That was not a human.
and surely surely he's all right man it's Thomas's birthday
he should be fine all right yeah I can upgrade this all
right we're gonna do that yep we got upgrade upgrade time
upgrade I think I'm making good progress
I also needed more heals uh let uh upgrade.
Can I upgrade this?
No, I actually can't.
I actually maxed out.
All right.
All in on gun now.
What is it?
Defense units are a class of weapons designed to overpower
opponents.
Use skillfully and they can decisively turn a fight, helping
against tough enemies or obstacles.
Performance scales according to upgrade level.
Okay, we do need the decoy gun.
going in.
Thrusters.
I don't think I have the material for thrusters, though.
It's a node.
Or whatever it is.
What?
Oh, I do!
I don't even remember when I got this.
Okay, now I have fast moves.
Yeah.
We really needed that.
Um...
Alright, guys.
Help me.
What's the meta?
What do we do?
next we will never fast move is fast oh yeah thrusters this
all right we have three charges now all right what do we
have a thousand three hundred dollars what should we do next
chat more hack what's the meta just don't get hit is that
maximum thrusters all right That's all of it.
Oh, I should know it's spawn rate more.
All right.
All in.
Oh, yeah, bingo.
I think I have bingo.
I do not have bingo.
You're leaving so soon?
Have a pleasant journey.
All right.
Hugh, you said later, right?
Is now a good time?
Yeah, here's your little TV.
Alright, and crit shot nest.
Okay, I'll go for crit shot next.
Alright, it's time for brain rot, child.
Let's go!
You see, before we had iPads, we had this.
A TV, Gemini girls.
Oh, it's starting.
Perfect.
I've rotted my AI.
Earth things are fun.
Watching TV is fun.
Don't you stare, say that.
I thought you liked TV.
I do.
But when I'm watching it, time just...
Exactly.
That's the whole point.
And the show is over.
I just feel like I wasted a bucket of time.
You created memories.
Ash Ketchum was here for all of us.
This episode is something to look forward to.
I don't want to wait.
I know the feeling.
it how dare you everything we print from the rem replica he
was there for us when we needed him the most everything yeah
everything seen all this stuff before anyways can't have too
many toys right toys i've never had toys before thanks hugh
no problem
where they got all of them do i need i'm missing one more i
like the little accessories that each of them have.
Alright, I think we got...
Oh, wait.
I should have another cat with bingo coin now.
Bingo!
I'll put it.
Alright, bingo.
Alright.
Now I just need to grab a new gun.
Um...
We'll start off on the...
I like the ride blaster, but I don't know yet if I want the
shockwave gun or the charge piercer.
I'm going to go back to shotgun for now.
Put new load.
Receive 10% more filament.
Okay, we're going to have that get that now that we have a
shotgun.
We want max HP or...
What do we...
Or pocket refinery or extended breach.
would we be better chat which one's better
hp cash all right we'll keep hp economy maxing just don't
get hit but mut you're right just don't as long as i don't
get hit it should be fine you're so right it's just that
just don't get You are super...
And I can be squishier.
Oh, the misery.
You're so right, guys.
Why do all of that when I can be even squishier?
Okay.
I saw one of them.
Wait.
What are you going to do?
Exactly.
Wait, they're walking away.
They're like, we will just walk away.
Oh my god, that's what they...
They just walk.
Wait a minute.
They're so smart.
I
didn't think they would just walk away like that there we go
they knew they fucking new.
Oops, that didn't all
right, we had three dashes, which was good.
That should be something.
Yeah, look.
It's like they're AI or something.
Hey, look at that.
The investment.
Look at that.
I invested.
On the filament economy.
Economy maxing.
Wait, what?
She's gonna eat it?
Ah,
yeah.
That is a chat.
They like to stick their...
Their mouths and everything.
Nominions.
I should be able to break this down.
Alright, that's useless now.
Good child.
Oh, she's gonna eat it.
Is she gonna eat it?
I'm gonna try something.
Holy fuck.
That's my AI.
I'm not backtracking, guys.
I don't care.
I'm not backtracked.
I don't care how much loot it gives me.
We go forward.
How is that?
I want to do my part.
I know.
You did it.
M&M, child.
That's my future.
Oh my god.
A doctor, lawyer, hacker, engineer, and rapper.
So what's your kid doing?
Oh.
High five!
She learned!
Yay!
yeah look at that i feed my ai the best stuff you trust my
ai uh scatter throat and click e okay
look at that train in all the right things magic just threw
up a warning your limb recycler usage is off the charts
think about it one tiny scrap or three junk chunks power
cost is the same It's using it on high cost items when
impossible.
Really that hard for you to grasp.
Keep your head in the game, Kevin.
Or the AI might decide your next thing to recycle.
Ooh.
Oh my god, my child's glowing.
What the fuck?
My gosh, she's like fully upgraded.
She's fucking glowing.
Alright, Laura time.
I'm looking.
Look at the size of that boat.
same thing?
Oh no.
Not Edis, not the AI.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
It's where Skynet happened.
I haven't seen anyone besides you since leaving the vault.
I can't believe we haven't found any survivors on a good
sign.
definitely not it's like it's like was it our fun or
whatever fuck called poppy play guys it's just like the
poppy playtime guys oh my god I can't wait for the chase
sequence are
you kidding me wait is that just a window oh that's where I
came from.
Like, I can't.
I can't.
Oh, that's a big baby.
What?
I regret the piercers just.
Just in case.
That's a lot of fucking robots in there.
Actually.
That's a lot of big robots.
Actually, maybe the shotgun.
Maybe.
because there are three enemies over there unless this is it
oh my god okay that's fine
okay there we go it works you scared
okay we'll do that and then we'll do that and then we'll do
that and then I realize I have a decoy all right nice it's
stopping he doesn't know he's so stupid he's like why isn't
it working why isn't he dying but little does he know oh
That's a critical.
Wait, I actually need that.
Take this!
Boom!
Good job, Kenny.
Oh, wait.
That's right.
I'm not using my ult yet, because I won't use it for the big
guy.
All right, we got him.
All right.
all right big guy tab and then oh that's fucking right get
out of here you got this sweetie i believe in you just in
case though just in case something happens though it's not
because i don't believe in you when i added the decoy but
just in you know sweetie just in case it's just back up it's
just it's just emergency backup i i believe in you it's just
a little plan b better safe than sorry little diana i did
believe in her yes it's caution.
Better safe than sorry.
You know, when we have a plan B for college, the safety
school?
You're doing great, Hugh.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry to believe in my child.
God, fucking every every time.
It's always a window.
This spot's all clean.
Fast work.
I appreciate it.
How much do I have?
Uh, I can upgrade.
Actually, yeah, upgrade.
Just in case.
I'm always Always the glass.
The glass always gets me.
Every time.
Every fucking time.
Which one?
I have a lot.
Okay.
We're on the gun.
Alright, what did we want to upgrade chat?
Crit, right?
Crit shot.
There we go.
We maxed that up.
Alright, what's after?
What should we do after crit shot?
guys we
do have enough but 900 you want to do the hacking stuff or
which one's the best option mod slot i don't think it's
maxed already riot blaster health
you want to do more of multi-hack all right i'll do
multi-hack then all right
there's the crusher we've downloaded that oh wait i should
have another bingo with like a cat i don't have that
unlocked yet though i wonder when you unlock that we meet
hello little girl so what's an amusement park oh right i
said i'd tell you about them they have this thing with a
cart and you ride up real high then come crashing back to
And this other thing you ride up in the air.
I'm not very good at explaining things.
She's a child, Hugh.
You know, the first thing, first ride I think of for a
child?
A carousel.
Oh, hey, nice.
We find it.
She got something for me.
He's like, you know what?
We good for a child?
A fucking roller coaster.
Yay!
Moriayo.
See, she's getting better.
She's learning.
Hey, it's actually pretty good.
Shows you're a real cat lover.
Does a cat have hands on the tail?
My sea eye slop.
I don't call it that.
Let's go.
Right on the fridge, it goes.
Yeah, too many toes.
Yep, that's AI.
Yep, the tail has fingers.
The tail, yep, that's definitely AI right there.
The tail has fingers, guys.
All right, let's see.
I should be able to equip that now.
Oh, we're good to go.
Don't worry, I'll just feed more, I'll feed more art into
it.
It'll get better.
It'll improve.
You can't believe Capcom has AI images in this cap.
I mean, where's the lie?
Okay, I'll go this way.
I'm doing my part.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Do you think he sees me?
How the fuck am I supposed to get it?
What the fuck?
Hello.
I generated a decoy.
Please respond.
There's no way.
You can't just walk away from me.
Alright.
Let's get to that tower.
That's right.
That's right!
That's what the cons tower is for.
You can't just fucking...
Walk away!
Oh.
Oh my god, he literally is just...
What am I supposed to do?
What?
There you go.
Good job, Kenny.
Finally opened up.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Can't believe he wasted my decoy.
Oh, I don't like the sound of that.
Why can't go in here now?
I'm going to the coffee shop.
Get my New York coffee.
There's another one.
New Vell.
Let's go in there.
I showed you my decoy.
respond I thought there would be a I legitimately thought
that bot would show up there and
yeah there is one more here I've been here before yeah this
is where I got the sniped the charge rifle it's just a
little shortcut now okay It's not backtracking when it's,
like, part of the path.
Yeah.
I'm just...
Okay, I'll use my riot blaster in this guy.
Alright, there we go.
Reloading?
Alright, get down.
There we go.
Goodbye.
I need the money.
Alright, there is a...
Oh, nice.
your friends like james was calm and collected oh no oh
that's right
ew no don't use the past says they're still alive and a word
friends even when you're angry friends sound complicated
that's what friends do nice so if there is a hole.
There's always a goal.
I think that's everything.
Map design.
I knew it.
I saw that hole.
I was like, there has to be something in there.
Why would there be a hole in the middle of nowhere?
My loot senses were tingling.
Just like here.
Got the box.
Oh.
There's a random hack here.
What is this supposed to hack?
Alright.
Alright, Diana.
Oh.
No, I only have $10.
Oh, 980.
Uh, but whatever spawn thing is behind me?
We can keep going.
I'm worried.
I don't know.
Fuck it.
I'm going back.
I'm going to take the risk.
Extra upgrades.
I don't know what to respond stuff because it's like the
soloist.
Yes, but they'll ignore you.
Yay!
I'm not as important.
I'm important just enough.
Oh, I need three.
Alright, guys.
What's next?
Decode or weapons, chat?
We're overjoyed.
Because we do have weapons or riot blaster.
I feel like riot blaster, maybe?
Because I've been using that a lot.
I'm going to do riot blaster.
I feel like I've been using that.
I mean, I could do overdrive, too.
Alright.
Oh, I have two coins.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Alright.
Get back on the tram.
Alright, here we go.
just look behind us and see where see if they're back there
oh there they are i was told they won't turn around i'm
gonna believe in that i'm gonna put all my trust in that see
any hidden loot here nope
Wow, what an open area with lots of weapons scattered
around.
Would be a shame if there was a boss right now.
Oh I didn't give permission.
Oh
What the fuck okay.
All right, it's just one right.
Oh
That's just one No, wait guys guys, it's just Just one.
Oh my god, and she's pregnant.
One really big one.
It's okay.
Decoy.
Really.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Woo.
All right.
I think that's...
I wish I had a railgun right about now.
It'll be pretty neat.
Wouldn't that be pretty neat, guys?
All right, let's try to see if there's a railgun near me.
Oh!
Okay, that's very inconvenient for me.
Oh, don't worry, I'm running.
Yay!
Okay, that's good.
That's good for me.
I can still keep packing.
It's alright.
He doesn't know.
Where is this?
Oh, fuck!
Okay, maybe he does know.
We're fine!
I'm hacking!
Oh no!
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
He doesn't know.
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, I was trying to figure out where the fuck was the
charge rifle.
Oh god.
Overdrive!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, get over here!
take this that's right bomb in mouth
okay oh my god where is he going i
just i was very confused i need you to know that oh no run
run you
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Good job, sweetie.
Wow!
Oh my god, where is he jumping to?
Alright, it's...
Oh, fuck, it's not fine.
Am I on high ground?
What?
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, that scared me.
I was like, higher ground.
Good job.
How you like this?
Okay.
Oh my god, was she open this fucking mouth!
Be careful!
Are you serious?
I'm trying.
I swear, Diana.
Are you serious?
I don't know how to dodge that.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Fuck.
Whoa.
What?
Oh, my God.
I actually might need to do that.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying.
It's so far out.
Oh, my
God, please.
Oh, God.
They're all up there.
It's everywhere.
Oh, it's everywhere How do I climb it up?
How
oh no The elevators where's the elevator?
Oh my god, there it is I found the elevator.
I found the elevator guys
Guys I found the elevator later
oh god oh
I see it baby we should be climbing up okay I see it I see
it now I see it too okay I figured it out guys wanna check
your gear holy fuck okay I made so I got so far Alright Now
that I know where it is Should be easier now Alright we
gotta change this though Okay we got that Alright I'm ready
Okay Oh I forgot to change a lot of my Oh fuck it whatever
doing it live i almost i almost brute-forced it i did i mean
that's pretty impressive though isn't it
if you think about it it is pretty impressive that i almost
brute-forced it
oh what the fuck Whoa.
All right.
We're just gonna hit the back.
We're gonna backshot it a little bit.
I'm trying!
All right, nice.
We got another antenna down.
Antenna down!
All right.
We need another gun though soon.
It's all right.
Oh, nice.
Another gun.
We actually need that.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Whoops.
All right, we got the head.
Guess it's my turn.
My turn!
Good job, Kenyon.
Oh, we got a run now.
We got a run.
Woo!
All right.
How do I charge it?
It's hurting something on the ground.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
Oh, this is...
Oh, come on.
That should be a hit.
It's too far.
I'm just gonna do that right now.
Just in case.
Oh, where are you gonna do?
Oh, oh, oh, there's so many, so many batters.
Yay!
You know what?
I'm going to put the decoy right here just in case.
I'm going to get rid of that just in case, too.
There we go.
We got another one down.
Is it?
It is!
It is down!
Oh my god!
What do you mean is purple right here?
It is!
Nice!
Oh!
What?
Get away from the blue circle!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're getting away.
Just casually just walking over things
There we go
Sorry he's not Okay nice we dodged Get dodged Oh my god get
dodged
It's okay
Nice Shot in the head Headshot
Oh my god I'm using everything thing please tell me it's the
other oh oh keep going keep going we made it we made it oh
my god there has to be an elevator here there has to be an
elevator here where's the elevator oh there it is
Okay.
Like, come on.
I'm fucking, okay.
That's fucked.
that's fucked right there I don't need to go up I'll just
stay here thank you very much I can't have anything oh my
god there you go
there you go there's no way there's no way there's no way
there we go there we go there's there we go get here now I
need get out of here I found the elevator I got it I fucking
did it I found the elevator we did it oh my god zero deaths
chat zero deaths
Oh shit, that's T.
That's pretty good.
Oh, we'll still be...
We still got this.
Oh, it's quick time event!
What?
Okay, yeah, I did got it.
That's right.
Get hacked!
Get fucking hacked!
Oh shit!
Quick, Diana!
Grab onto me!
Nice.
Father of the Year.
It's alright.
Fall down, Matrice and Rilo.
Diana.
We are.
We're a team.
We are!
Yay!
Hi-five!
Oh my god.
Look at that.
Investment is pulling through.
We made it!
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh my god, yeah, she 3D-printed that building so fast.
Alright.
Uh, key card that raises your shelter level.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can do more things at the shelter now.
Yeah, we can, Diana.
Alright, let's grab.
oh my god all right who cares about loot i guess i hope i
got my loot i don't even know
same as everywhere else where are the humans they like 3d
print a ship and sell bag surely right
access denied
It's like the hour of joy all over again.
Where can I?
Let's see.
How about here?
The pterodone?
I got these other stops as well.
There's gotta be something there we can use.
Okay, transports.
Yeah.
Wonder if they're still online.
Oh!
Look!
It's back!
Oh, the cat's back!
The holographic cat.
Can you hear me?
What the fuck?
Please respond.
The talking holographic cat.
What the fuck?
It's me.
Eight.
I borrowed this little one to contact you.
It's good we found each other.
Talking cat?
Yes.
I was caught in the moonquake.
here oh there's no way out i can't even move oh shit wait
how long has she been trapped in this has to be a trap
there's no way
there's no way that has to be a trap no human is named it's
an ai it has to be like like diana like beta or some shit.
It's like she knew you.
You two met?
Do not trust the AI cat.
It's like when people were making the cats like shooting
gun.
You remember like those AI videos of the cat at the door
with a fucking machine gun?
There's something going down.
Let's go find out what?
You found the elevator.
Boy, the cat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
a shotgun cat.
Chat and rock.
Is this real?
Is this cat real?
Alright, nice.
I sent you my hollow cat, We're in spot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to use...
Yay!
Yuck dog.
Level two.
Do not trust the cat.
Diana, is this real?
Alright, I did grab stuff from it.
Founding upgrade limits, expanding across the shelf.
Oh, I can upgrade!
Okay, I feel like...
Maybe I should start upgrading my...
Maybe I should start upgrading my HP.
Now...
Thank God!
I could keep upgrading Diana now.
Alright.
Now print mode chips.
Change your hacking mode.
Each mode triggers different effects when enemies are open.
Turns open nodes into boosting damage of your next hack.
Oh.
Causing friendly fire.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom again.
I'll be right back.
I hydrated a lot.
What are we upgrading, guys?
What are we upgrading?
Anya, Zechra, Nexi, Rice, Allen, Mehdi, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you.
All right, what's the plan, guys?
Ooh, auto-hacking.
Wait.
All right.
To activate, consumes a small to automatically complete.
Oh, but I'm going to complete my...
I don't think I need an auto-hack, I feel like.
To reveal enemy...
Object scan.
Okay, we definitely need this.
Offense mode.
All right.
Let me grab this.
first so at least i have objects again all right i got you a
microchip a little snacky all right nice okay and then
offense mode i will grab offense mode too
and i don't think i i i can see the weak point i don't think
i need to no i can see it with my eyes you know like I have
eyes for that get the bot scan I mean it's sort of easy to
see oh fine wait fine it's only 150 dollars anyway you just
want me to feed Diana with more food
all right update synchronizing new functions This is where
our RAM's going.
This is why RAM prices are going up, guys.
God damn it, yeah.
What?
Complete them to receive cap and coins.
We even have a new stamp board available for your enjoyment.
Yay.
We gotcha.
Can our training sims.
They're less lethal than the real thing.
Did you know Capri's son?
Yeah, you just want me to give her some Capri's son.
Upgrade components.
Oh!
Upgrade components!
I can do this.
Wait.
Reach target area 90.
Okay, parkour.
Destroy all our storage boxes complete with VIN.
Alright, I can do that.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Surely I can do that, right?
Alright.
There you go.
Oh shit.
Hurry.
There you go.
I made it.
Now we run.
Run, Hugh.
Run.
There you go.
Easy.
Look at that.
Training complete.
And I got my upgrade.
Perfect.
That was the run.
I knew it.
Alright.
What's this?
Collect seven signal data in 60 seconds.
Complete within 50 seconds.
That gives me a Oh, per lunar.
I need that, actually.
What is this?
Collect seven signal data.
I actually don't know what signal data is.
We need all the loot we can get to maximize.
Alright.
What is signal data?
oh all right i know what signal data is i just so that's
it's literally just parkour again whoa oh my god that was
close all right go go go
oh my god we made it we made it just in time oh no come on
oh 16 seconds come on The last one is right over here.
Oh!
Nine.
E.
Done!
I might not have been done, guys.
I might not have been done with the challenge.
Oh, no, no, no, oh shit, I got those too cocky there.
All right, I got locket.
I got locket.
All right, now, done.
For real, done, for real.
Look at that.
Just wanted to 6-7 your chat.
Didn't...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Definitely the plan.
Totally on purpose, guys.
I mean, enemies with weapons.
What in the fuck?
Why can't I hack him?
Does he not want me to hack him?
I guess not.
What the fuck?
It's not giving me the charge.
There we go.
Alright.
That's fine.
Is it?
Oh my god, it is definitely not over.
Don't worry, I can finish this fast though.
Where's the last guy?
Get over here!
Boom!
Oh.
Oh my gosh, please.
Boom!
Not even close.
I thought I was holding a charge rifle for some reason.
It just all blurred together.
Common is the slow and insidious killer.
Thank you.
Jigay, thank you.
Good morning from Germany, everybody.
Thank you.
Oh, wait, this might be hard.
Wait, this one might be a little difficult.
Alright.
The floor is lasers.
Oh my god, 50 seconds.
Wait, I have to complete without dodging?
How?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's cheeky.
Whoa!
I sat in the middle.
What the?
At least gamers looked up.
Okay.
I was just like, excuse me, they go up now.
that's evil that is so evil but we got it we got her
upgrades how is that a new stamp board secure oh my god i
need to secure it in the mass production array to unlock
nearest tram station all right guess we're not doing that a
happy shelter life all right i should have enough upgrades
now
Or I could go all in.
That's right.
I'm having enough.
I'll just...
Alright, I do have money now.
Alright, what's next, guys?
What do we upgrade next, chat?
Oh, critical shot.
Never mind.
I know I just asked you, but I'm going to upgrade critical
shot.
Emergency when knockback press at the right.
Nah.
See, one node.
Confused?
i don't have enough another slot though so i don't know i
should use it
i'll just save i'm gonna save up
the other thrusters is pretty good yeah but that requires
them to hit me what if they don't well what if they just
don't hit me guys
okay hacking modes for you you can only quit one mode chip
at a time Okay, there's the offensive mode.
I still don't have enough mods for this, so...
Just don't get hit.
Exactly.
I will do one more area, and then we'll call it.
How many areas...
Does anyone know how many areas...
I know the game just came out yesterday, but does anyone
know how many areas there are?
Like, am I halfway through?
Or, like...
Am I very...
Am I just in the beginning?
You know where we can find this eight character five all
right.
We're on a third area.
I am not halfway.
Okay, that is good to know Oh No, just oh We replicated the
nature.
Okay, there's stuff over here and there's stuff here This
place took some serious funding
Yeah, I was gonna say where did they get this money Excuse
me.
I feel like I am not getting paid enough now after being
here.
Seems I'm not getting paid enough for my services.
Oh, I thought I could go up here.
I really like the boss fights, though.
Oh, she knows birds.
She knows what birds are.
Wait, we can print...
So we did print an animal.
want to touch it.
I can't touch it.
You wouldn't print a bird, would you?
Wait, that didn't scan.
Is that not?
Oh.
Okay, so I can't rely on this.
Rely on the scan.
Because that one didn't get picked up.
So, you remember anything about eight?
No.
I I just felt like I'd heard her voice.
Every day you can meet someone who can talk using a cat.
Pretty strange.
Not like we got a lot of leads.
So yeah, we can't reach you.
Alright.
Nick's family.
They deserve to hear what happened.
You know, in person.
Alright, I gotta keep scanning.
Make sure I get everything.
I don't think I can go up here.
But, oh, nice.
Upgrades.
That's really good so that I can find like the these items
too because these are the important one the important.
Oh, there you are Yeah, I'm not wasting it
Yeah, I'm not wasting shit on you Not wasting those mods How
do I get up there?
Wait, there was an item up here I saw my eyes Oh, there it
is.
Parkour time.
I knew it.
Okay.
Maybe I don't know it.
Yeah.
Maybe I just go up here.
There we go.
I knew it!
Can't hide from me.
We can use that back up.
Can't hide the loot.
I'd have to order a scan now.
I'm so paranoid.
You got something?
There's REM data nearby.
Let's take it back to the shelter.
Wait, we...
We printed a tree?
Oh my god.
Silence knows no bounds.
Wait.
I thought we grew this.
We can't even grow...
Oh my god!
We printed a tree!
Samurai!
What the heck with that?
So much for the beauty of nature.
Oh.
Alright.
Now it's my turn.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Can you pull us?
Bounce right off.
Don't worry, I got the high ground.
What is he gonna do now?
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
There's...
Don't see any soil here.
Is this not...
No, that's just...
Is that not soil?
I can't believe it.
We printed a tree.
We can't even fucking grow trees here.
That's soil, right?
That...
Did we print the soil?
We printed the soil, didn't we?
We fucking printed the soil.
Didn't we print?
in a samurai.
Welcome to the Terra Dome.
Using the latest lunar filament output technology built on
plant growth algorithm.
We fucking out.
We bring the complex environments of Earth to life here on
this lunar surface.
Step aboard the central lift and explore every area.
Everything you see here was printed with the one and only No
filament.
Certain research areas involve hazardous experience.
Oh my god.
We fucking cracked the algorithm, guys.
The fucking plot algorithm.
We did it.
We've cracked the code.
Another one?
Please initiate a manual reboot of the limb.
Alright.
What the fuck?
What?
What do we do?
Oh, is it like those acid washes?
in like 3D printing.
Damn.
Yiddish is playing games with us again.
That tree was getting smaller.
But then Yiddish got in the way.
Can't forget you.
Wow, we got this.
Uh, thousand...
Oh, yeah.
We can't afford an upgrade.
Alright, heading back.
Control Z to plant.
God has abandoned us We can just print a god at this point
I have enough for the No we need one more Oh is it doing mod
slot or no slot I feel like mod slot right Because like
there's no We don't have any extra hacking stuff at the
moment.
It's EC thrusters.
I don't want to do that.
No, I feel like we don't need that.
I'm going to grab...
Should we do mod slot?
Chat?
I wait.
Yeah?
Repair?
I'll never get hit.
Well, you think I'm going to get hit or something?
Alright, let's grab Opener mini stays exposed Longer
Actually, let's get that No, it's fine, we'll get Heals That
proceeds to get Hit Heroes never die You know that's what
they You know that they say
Um Invincible.
Ta-da!
Title card, title card.
Alright.
Nothing.
Oh, there's the cat.
Eat!
Hello, cat.
I don't trust her.
I feel like she's like, I don't eat us or something.
Try to set us up for a trap.
I don't eat.
this or like she's like diana like beta or something okay
hang in there right there's gotta be another way i don't
know i've trust issues you've got something there's like
there's like so many things here oh my gosh which way do i
go i could i could could go anywhere.
All right, we'll go to here.
We'll go there here.
Maybe she's evil, Diana.
Yeah.
Honestly, I won't be surprised.
Oh my god, did we print the butterflies?
Oh my god, we printed buttercake.
I know I keep being surprised, but like, I keep thinking
like, that should be the limit to the printing, right?
It just doesn't bring a smile to your face the same way oh
my god we printed everything i'm not wasting that node
like i see you you're just like chilling over there yeah i'm
not wasting i'm not wasting anything on these guys
uh we'll grab the shotgun just in case that makes me wonder
like can we print humans inside teradome lumification oh oh
okay uh print trees are fully managed by ai in the eco
modern lab from growth to dismantling our goal is to develop
trees that can continue expanding their structure naturally
with water and sunlight even after printing and now some
manual handling is still required simply insert a gen chip
into the dedicated replicator to output the regulated amount
of luna filament No, but she's not real.
Jokey, she's real.
You know what I mean?
She's not...
She literally ate ram.
Guys, that child ate ram in front of us.
I hear him.
Nah.
She's somewhere.
Okay, wait.
Ew.
There we go.
What did I do, though, with that?
No.
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
Bingo!
And bingo was his name.
There's a lot of stuff around me, apparently.
Okay, she doesn't need that.
It has to be.
this way then
oh shit no shit yeah it did what oh all right that's easy
okay the rocket launch all right eat the ram little girl
growth pile of trees each ship promotes one growth all right
holds a license to generate quasi-organic plant material
it's worth a shot
Okay.
Yay!
We made our own... We printed a tree!
I'm gonna shoot it from here.
Is there any more items here?
Okay, there's one up here.
There's also one up there, but how do I get there?
Okay.
How do I get over there?
Oh, that's a secret wall, isn't it?
That is the most secret wall I've ever seen secretly.
What do we have here?
There we go.
That item scan is so useful.
How much RAM?
How much is RAM in the future?
I won't be surprised if it's a lot.
With all these AI kids running around.
I'm pretty sure she just...
She just ate like 10 RAM since we got...
out here i hardly ever go back to my own room anymore i just
love setting up a wall in some corner and working to my
heart's content is it just one guy oh no it's sharon i don't
remember i remember the other guys who set up these hideouts
like is she just obsessed with hideouts i suddenly find
somewhere else to stake out yesterday a new scientist joined
i mean we could print a ram honestly like yeah i was gonna
say sharon what is wrong with you sharon You're right, I
could just print RAM for it.
I was hoping for a spirited discussion to talk about where
my favorite movies, about events, material, all I wanted to
do was talk about my favorite movies and places I wanted to
visit.
Sorry, I really don't have time for that right now.
He also kept asking what room I was in.
I fit just to get him off my back, only to catch him
sneaking around behind me.
Jeez, I put up, oh, that's creepy.
I put up a wall of my mobile replicator, and finally managed
to give him the slip.
I bet I'm the only one here who could get one.
Prince is that fast.
He looked like he saw a ghost, and I got a good laugh of it.
Maybe I'll try that a few more times.
Alright.
Yeah, having all those hideouts didn't fucking save her from
the robot eye uprising.
And there's an item here.
Oh.
I don't know if I like this area.
It's not because there's grass.
It just feels...
It definitely feels a lot more confusing.
Alright, nice.
Not because of the grass.
It's just...
Definitely feels a bit more confusing.
No, no, I want...
Wait, actually, let me...
Seven.
All right.
I think I can take this.
That's right.
Let me in.
This shit is nothing.
Oh, fuck.
What is that?
Wait a minute.
I didn't sign up for that.
Oh, fuck.
What?
is wait you're right I didn't even notice that guy was
aiming at us
oh what all
right let's just get that guy out of way okay wait excuse me
I have hacked you So, how is it bouncing right off if I'm
hacking?
Woo!
Oh, shit!
I was...
Whoa!
Sorry, I was a little...
Played a little too cocky there.
Oh.
Am I gonna do that?
I don't want to do critical hit on that.
I'm not wasting a critical hit.
What the fuck?
Wait, where is his weak point?
I can't see it.
Oh, there it is.
It's his head.
Alright, nice.
I think I might have to use a decoy.
We'll just...
wait here.
It's five.
We'll just wait here.
The decoy is still working.
Alright.
Nice.
Offensive.
Oh, I didn't even see that guy.
That's who he was trying to kill.
Alright, nice.
Get hacked.
Whoa!
Is he still there?
Oh, he is.
Whoa!
Oh, chill out.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
That's not where I wanted to go.
Where am I?
I see it gives me time to heal though.
I think I'm at...
No, no.
I don't need the hack yet.
It's fine.
I'm back.
I'm back, baby.
Miss me?
Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
Those thrusters would have been nice right now.
I don't need it.
I'm fine.
That's pussy shit.
Look at that.
See, everything's fine.
We're all okay.
Wait, actually?
Might as well.
This might be something... Why would they give it to me?
Oh my god, there's a lot more.
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
Surely it's not coming towards me.
Wait, why is it not opening up?
What the fuck?
You can't just close your head like that.
Open up the head.
Open up.
There we go.
I'm pretty sure there's still people up here.
Okay, we don't need hack yet.
Right on.
It's fine, we don't need it yet, guys.
Okay, I might need it.
I might need it.
Never mind.
I actually might need the hack.
Wow, that was a lot easier.
Ooh, what is that?
Good job, Kenny.
Oh no.
Oh no, reloading?
Be careful.
All right.
All right, last one.
That has to be the last one.
All right.
Down!
Boop!
Yeah, no, you're not, I'm not wasting critical hit.
Yay!
that not even hard that hard wasn't even that difficult all
right there are wait is that outside the area or yeah that's
here nice
okay nice everything shut down that should be everything
yeah that's just outside i'm sure yeah but he was like so
far too it just didn't feel worth it you know I knew there's
upgrade containers here
I'm trying to figure if that's like here or outside is
that here no right it's like here but how do they get there
yeah yeah I can't.
Okay, I gotta fucking go back all over again.
God damn it.
Well, at least I got a tiny bit of money.
Sorry, I can run.
I'm zooming.
I don't know.
I'm not a really huge fan of this area.
It feels like a lot more confusing for me.
Alright.
Open sesame.
Yay!
The lateral damage.
Oh.
Wait, that's good.
Okay, now the crit shot is even more worth it.
Hey.
It's all below me.
Is that it?
Is there no?
Oh, I guess I have to go back from where I came from.
There you go.
All right, I'm gonna call it here.
Let's upgrade it.
We'll call it here.
The grass.
What is it called?
I got...
I got like...
This one with the grass level.
I got filtered by the grass area.
The grass area filtered.
through to me.
I was like, oh, I don't know.
It's too much.
It's too much grass.
9 out of 10.
What can I feel?
Wait, I got a new upgrade for something, but I don't know
what.
What do I get a new upgrade for?
They're like, you can't upgrade something, but what?
He went and told me to touch grass and I refused.
I was like, All right, I'm not getting thrusters.
You can't make me.
I'm going to get the hacking gauge.
All right, that was fun.
All right.
Oh, yeah, before.
But don't go yet.
Don't go yet, guys.
We're doing our little giveaway.
If you guys don't remember, I almost forgot to.
Oh, my God.
I'm not saved.
Oh, that would be so...
I hope that had auto saved.
That would be so awkward.
All right, it is a giveaway time.
Uh, I mean, for those who don't know, I am giving away 10
codes, 10 game codes on Steam, on Steam.
So, um, the rules are, uh, again, huge thank you to MSI for
today's sponsor.
I had a blast playing Pragmata.
It is a very fun, I think, uh, uh, I think it definitely is
like the game is more fun, lot of fun playing like i really
love all the mechanics like the hacking and the shooting
mechanics um especially as an fps enjoyer um i'm very glad
that the game is very fun to play so thank you shank youtube
msi uh for today's sponsor if you want to support the stream
and support msi uh please feel free to click on the link pin
in the chat and the description below um there's a new deal
right now where if you have uh where basically uh if you buy
select the msi monitor and post a review on the platform you
can claim a pragmatic pc game code and if you already
purchased an msi product before and purchased msi selected
mpg uh qd olen monitor you can get another extra stream
steam wallet of up to 100 us dollars uh so yeah huge thank
you again uh i personally use also use their monitors um as
a competitive gamer it really does help a lot because
especially frames wise uh because it goes all the way i have
a 500 hertz monitor and it really is helpful for me when it
comes to climbing Elo and stuff, climb ranks.
Anyway, yeah, feel free to click on the link and support
MSI, especially when they supported the stream and provided
you drag loads with 10 free codes.
So, if you guys get the code, please remember to follow the
at Doki merch account.
I'm gonna tweet, let's see, I'm gonna paste it real quick so
people will know.
Doki merch.
I'm gonna paste it.
it real quick so this is the dokey merch account if you uh
if you win the giveaway please make sure to follow the dokey
merch account and dm them and show your proof that you are
uh that your twitter account is connected to the youtube
account that won the giveaway um and then they should give
you the code you can you have to claim the code within 24
hours if you don't claim It will get, it'll just got auto, I
guess like, it'll just auto go to someone else, I guess.
So it does expire.
Let me check if the mod is, okay, the mod is not awake
today, right?
Not today.
I mean, he's gonna wake up soon.
And I like he'll never be awake.
But you know what I mean?
When the mod is awake on the Doki merch account, they will
DM you.
to dm so don't yeah so um do not worry if they don't reply
back instantly with your game code they will reply in about
an hour or two i think it's like within two out like women
one to three hours i'm trying to figure out when the mod is
who runs the doki merch account will uh will be awake i'm
just trying to gauge right now usually he is awake within
three hours but if you don't receive response to within
three hours it is because he is um he is still sleeping oh
you'll send him a list thank you otherman you'll send him
the list of winners all right so let's see uh let me make
sure i have all right all right to enter please feel free to
do exclamation point enter to enter the giveaway all right
let me put the rules out too in on in chat real quick i
might need you guys help me count as well because i feel
like i'm gonna i'm gonna lose count to how many people i
have fucking uh pulled in the giveaway so i will require
assistance um all right let's grab the text real quick oh my
gosh she's watching tv isn't she right now i i can hear her
watching tv in the background point nation point enter if
you get picked dm at doki merch on twitter too clip i hear
mario wait i hear i hear i hear mega man in the background
who's playing mega man right now who is it not you he's
playing mega man isn't he i sorry i heard mega man in the
background it's like who who is
exclamation point enter all right there we go i know it's
not centered he's gonna piss he's gonna annoy people but it
can't be bothered right now uh all
right i'm gonna give you guys a little countdown before i
pull and even when i when i start pulling winners you can
still keep doing exclamation point enter you only do get one
entry by the way the more you put it in it doesn't mean
you're gonna get more entries but if you haven't put an
entry yet while i'm Doing the giveaway, pulling the giveaway
winners.
Do not worry, you still have time.
We have 10 winners today, so Cosmo, thank you for the five
gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, I'm going to pull up the first winner.
Gio, congratulations, Gio.
I'm winning.
All right, Gio, are you here, Gio?
You got to make sure.
I can see if you type a message, too.
Congratulations on winning the first game code.
Congratulations All right, Gio Wait, yeah What
Congratulations Gio, make sure again to DM DM Doki merch on
Twitter to claim Within 20 Yeah, within 24 hours Just make
sure Let me just do that DM Doki At Doki merch on Twitter
There we go All right All right.
Next winner.
Winner number two.
Raskat.
Congratulations, Raskat.
Yeah.
More pragmatic.
Congratulations.
Winner number two.
Raskat, are you here?
I got to see a message from you before I go on to the next
one so you know you won.
Rask it Rask come on say something you just won a you just
won a free game Rask
I am alive okay that's good to know I'm glad you're alive I
got a little worry there like did a meteor strike your house
the moment I pulled your pulled you as a winner I got a
little worried congratulations Rask like I said remember to
DM Dookie merch on Twitter All right, next winner.
All right.
Next giveaway winner Strange 44 Congratulations not a yeah,
I got to make sure you're not a bot as well Like I don't I
make sure like no someone didn't set up like 500 bots to do
exclamation enter to win one game code What to be fair prog
mod is like what 70 Canadian dollars so like I won't blame
you It is it is pretty pricey so i will not blame you
yeah let's see all right nice all right next up next up
Andreas G6884 congratulations yay wait what is that is that
winner number four I've already lost count I'm sorry just as
long as I've streamed in a while I've been I haven't
streamed more than three hours in a long time so I I'm
trying to get used to streaming in past the three hour mark
congratulations I'm here nice All right, he's here to claim
it.
All right, next up, winner number five.
We're halfway through it.
We're zooming through here.
Snoozy 294.
Congratulations, Snoozy 294.
Are you here, Snoozy?
Also, everybody, remember.
Remember to, like I said, if you, uh, to, to DM Joe Kimich
on Twitter to claim, make sure you have proof that this is
your YouTube account.
just be just be because you gotta be like i'm snoozy 294 and
then you're not but you're not actually not we will be
checking proof guys that you are snoozy 294 we will be
checking all right snoozes here all right winner winner
chicken dinner all right who is winner number six winner
number six nexi congratulations nexi
another free pragmata congratulations nexie I think this is
like I think I know like nexie and she has been entering a
lot of the giveaways this is the first time look see
anything is possible guys I told you anybody can win she
okay I'm not checking it twice it's why I delegate see you
keep entering eventually You'll win the gotcha.
It can happen to you.
It can even happen to you.
Keep gambling.
But in game.
Now you're alive.
All right.
Azumiko.
Congratulations.
Okay, where am I at?
Okay, one, two.
Guys, what number am I at?
Three, four, five, six, seven.
Wait, one, two.
three, four, five, six, seven.
Okay, three more left.
Three more.
Congratulations, Azumi.
Oh, shit.
She was too busy clapping for the other winner.
She didn't realize she also won.
Congratulations, Azumi.
Another game for you and for you too.
All right.
Winner number eight.
Robert Stahl.
Congratulations, Robert.
Oh, now you have to make a Twitter.
Wait, now you have to make a Twitter.
make a Twitter account.
Aren't you the guy that said, oh yeah, I don't have a
Twitter account.
Well, too bad.
Now you have to make a Twitter account to get Pragmata.
That's right.
See, I remember.
It's not even my Twitter.
It's her merch Twitter.
But I have to really buy my merch, by the way.
Since you're checking out the Doki merch, account where
we're gonna buy my merch like i reactivated my old one yeah
you can't escape that's right that is a sign that is
actually a divine intervention right there you're like come
back there's there's no way no way i'm gonna win i don't
even have a twitter account look at that they want you back
on twitter bro the algorithm calls for you Where am I at?
Do I have, like, winner number nine, right?
Let me check.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
All right, winner number nine.
Last two, guys.
Last two.
Doremi-Ku.
Congratulations.
You have also won.
Pragmata.
Also, I don't know if you guys are going to try and play the
game to get further than me before I...
before my next playthrough on site.
I don't know if you guys don't want to get spoiled or not,
but yeah.
Adore Me Q.
Congratulations.
I'm just waiting for you to respond to make sure you're
alive and no meteor struck your house before your name was
called.
Dore Me Q.
Is Dore Me Q in the lobby right now?
Is she present?
She or he?
Doremiq I wonder it's like she was like I didn't get caught
she's like I'm not gonna win there's two left.
I'm leaving I
Doremiq I need you to respond
Doremiq It's gonna be very awkward because If you don't
respond we might have to pull someone else.
Oh my god, you gotta stick to the end Doremiq Oh my god, I
think they're like, there's two left.
I'm not gonna win.
I'm gonna leave.
I'm not a winner But Dora and me, you did win.
You actually did win.
Oh, oh snap Dora and his ear is Dora and me cute.
They tapped out point time.
Wait, they're here.
They're alive.
See Dora and me cute?
Anything can happen if you stay a bit longer.
They live.
Remember to DM Doki Merch on Twitter and claim your Pragmata
code.
They made it.
Yo.
He survived the impact.
All right.
Congratulations.
You get to keep your code.
Just remember to, like I said, DM Doki Merch account.
There is 24 hours to claim the code, by the way, guys.
24 hours to claim it.
All right.
Last but not least, the final winner.
Drum roll, please.
Last winner.
George, congratulations on winning the last code for
Pragmata.
Yay!
Congratulations, everybody, who won the Pragmata code.
But do not worry, if you're like, oh, I didn't win.
We do a lot of streams with MSI, especially for a lot of new
game releases, and they provide a lot of game codes for you,
Dragon.
So do not worry.
There might be more codes in the future for you guys to have
a chance to win.
I know a lot of some of the people that have won today,
they've been entering these giveaways, you know, for the
last like three other sponsors.
And some of them just won today.
So, you know, it could happen to any of you guys.
give up it could happen to any one of you guys to get a free
game from msi like i said again huge shout out again and
thank you to msi for today's sponsor um it was this game has
been really fun i would i honestly if i didn't get filtered
by the grass level i could have kept going i could i was
like i'm too tired but as i kept exploring uh the grass the
tree slash grass level i was just like i'm done too much
grass grass wins again i was like If it wasn't for the
grass, I could have kept going.
I don't know.
I just don't like, I don't know.
I'm not a huge fan of the level design for this one.
The other ones were fun, but this level, like, New York
City, the New York City was really cool.
Just something about the tree environment, the level design
for it, which just didn't click for me.
It just didn't click.
I think it was a little, I think it's just a bit more
confusing than the other levels, like everything blends in
more so it feels harder to like explore than i uh i'm glad i
had the item scan because i think if i didn't have the item
scan i would get it would be like harder to explore and like
figure out where like everything is hidden and stuff um any
guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up
and move around to get that blood flowing say it for me head
to bed because you deserve it uh remember tomorrow's a big
announcement um at 3 p.m phd or pdt i really I feel like I
know I heard like it's not supposed to be PST it's supposed
to be PDT I was like I'm actually is actually PDT but like
when I say PST we all know I mean that PDT yeah because like
I don't fucking keep track of daylight savings time I I just
I just assume we all know what time that is yeah yeah and
there's anyway uh uh I'll see you guys tomorrow with
chibi-doki uh uh uh for uh the big announcement and then
everything will be revealed i can finally do log streams
again everything will be revealed tomorrow so i i had to do
like short streams and why i had to travel and why i've been
so tired i've been working so much hey guys i will see you
guys next time everybody bye guys